[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
let's talk about our democracy for a
minute
but let's do it in a way that makes the
snowflakes heads explode let me be clear
before this podcast begins we are loud
loud
and do not give a [__]
is that Tony Michaels podcast real and
raw political and social commentary the
freedom to oppress the rights of other
people is not Liberty you [__] eating
[__] ah the smell of freedom of speech
this is the Tony Michaels podcast and
this is Tony Michaels
hey Tony [__] em
[Music]
traitor this
traitor that
oh baby
[Music]
who's gonna guess it
some little fragile white male racist
some ammo sexual 2A bro
of course is the Discord leaker
couldn't get any more cookie cutter than
that could you
nope
a lot of people are pointing out how
fast
he was arrested like how fast he was
arrested
a lot of people are saying if he was
arrested within minutes of them knowing
who this guy was which it seemed like it
was about hours
why can't they arrest Donald Trump
well
I guess we'll find out why
maybe it's because they figure Donald
Trump is just gonna do himself in you
know I always say don't take the shovel
out of their hands when they're digging
their political grave
and nor should we take the shovel out of
their hands we should hand them a
backhoe we should encourage it you know
what we should crowdfund
for a fascist backhoe to Bear to dig
their political Graves to bury
themselves in
you see it this morning from this ad
have you seen this ad that Trump put out
of putting fingers are on oh my God
you know
Liz I I know Liz Harrington has to watch
this someone from the Trump Camp has to
be watching this [__] show they have
to be right
every time we
put something out there in the universe
for them they capture it
this at seriously this ad
Republicans especially the Ron DeSantis
Defenders
um online this morning are saying this
is this is a Democrat strategy
this seems like an ad from Democrats
right it is
to encourage the puddin fingers Civil
War what Hells didn't know yeah let's do
that
you you think we're gonna just we're
like no that's bad form Trump
no it's hilarious it's [__] hilarious
that that the savior of their party
from Trump
is going to be easier to beat than Trump
like think about it they're gonna crush
him and even look listen I I actually
again
I'm not too sure that Ron DeSantis is
going to get in this fight uh over the
over the last few days Fort Lauderdale
has been flooding and he went to Ohio to
stand and talk in front of tens of white
people for them to half-ass clap for him
to say woke a thousand times I'm not
[__] you
I I'm I'm probably not gonna have time
well you know what we probably will have
time today to show a little bit of this
uh these clips from
from this event that Rhonda Santos had
in front of tens of white people and
they half-assed clap for him to say the
word woke in Ohio
he went to Ohio as his state is
underwater
and of course you know they're bashing
him for that which I mean Ron look if
you're gonna be the governor be the [__]
Governor if you're going to run present
run for president hey Liz if you're
listening that's the next ad you should
run
if anyone from the Trump cramp camp is
listening that's the next ad you should
run
is be Governor don't be governor do that
one
it's gonna be a good one
[Laughter]
I don't I don't know if they're
listening but it [__] feels like it
sometimes it really does so and Trump
can't if you're listening that's the
next ad you need to do is Ron DeSantis
needs to decide to be the governor not
be the governor and show footage of Fort
Lauderdale underwater and then show him
doing the Jeb Bush please clap moment in
Ohio do that please
anyways so this pudding fingers Civil
War this they finally got around to
making the ad
and it's the Trump the Trump War Room
pack or whatever the hell it is make
America great again incorporated or some
[__] whatever [__] you know mob name
they gave his Super PAC
um that's the one that's running this ad
the best part about it is literally
if Ron DeSantis wins which again I don't
even know if he's gonna get in his
window is closing again
it's closing rapidly as as because
here's the thing when you're talking
about presidential primaries especially
Republican Presidential primaries
momentum matters right momentum matters
in a primary
and if you lose momentum you may never
gain it back
and if you gain an advantage you may
want to take that advantage and make the
best of it the problem is the problem is
with the Trump indictments we thought we
might see a few things
we thought we might see this total
backing of Donald Trump and an
abandonment of Ron DeSantis which isn't
exactly the case but Maga got more
staunch in their support with Trump so
it seems to be that's where the wind is
at its back Rhonda santis did not did
not rise
to be a superstar after Trump was
indicted that's my sign that the window
is absolutely closing in on him and he's
not going to be able to enter this race
and even if he does it's it's worse than
[__] Nikki Haley or or Ansa
Hutchinson or
Tim Scott opening an exploratory
campaign to act like he's running or
this Vivek guy have you seen this Vivek
guy I don't know what Donald Trump pack
is paying the vet to run but it's kind
of pathetic Vivek it really is pathetic
I'm just saying
but I'm telling you the Civil War is
what we want because we can just take
these ads and play these ads regardless
regardless if Ron DeSantis wins or not
we just have to point out the division
in their party that's all we have to do
is to break them apart and to wedge them
that's it that's all we have to do I
mean we have to run against them we have
to politicize every single issue
top to bottom side to back and and
that's what this that's what this
classified documents leak is you got to
politicize the [__] out of this I'm
telling you this is going to be very
important
and because already Marjorie Taylor
green is acting like this is the new
Kyle Rittenhouse of the Republican party
they have [__] totally dunked and
threw away Kyle Rittenhouse
into the young Superstar America First
Nazi party they dunked him in the trash
it's now this James uh treveccia wow how
do you say it
it's a weird last name it's spelled
weird
anyways at the trader he's he's in
Massachusetts Army National Guard
employee
um he's a racist apparently he makes
social media videos like Kid Rock but
instead of you know yelling [__] bed Bud
Light he yells racial epithets
an anti-semitic epithets into the camera
while he's firing the gun almost it's
almost like he wants to use the gun for
that purpose is what it seems like when
you watch a video like that I don't know
maybe I'm wrong maybe I'm way off my
rocker hmm
but uh this uh this fragile little white
boy
uh yesterday was arrested and it what's
crazy is the camera angle because there
was a news helicopter above his house
and he was on his back porch reading uh
mineconf I mean that's what I thought it
was it was a really big thick book so I
would imagine it's probably his
autograph copy of mineconf possibly I
mean apparently every Republican desires
to have historical value in their
personal library with autographed copies
of mineconf so I'm sure this James Gang
had his own I don't know I can't confirm
what book it is I'm just saying it seems
like a popular thing on the right for
these [__] to want historical
value
they're Nazis that's what I'm trying to
say
um
but uh he comes out the uh the feds are
there the armed with body armor
because they know this this gay is a
[__] nutcase he's a lunatic and I've
seen his videos online so um he backs up
to them if you watch this video and
we're gonna watch it today he backs up
to him for them to arrest him and they
take him away apparently uh uh either
yesterday or this morning in the
courthouse in the federal courthouse as
he's being arraigned
um people were upset that is that his
dad was telling him that he loves him in
the courthouse or something so I I mean
you know if it was your kid your kid was
uh driven to extremism online uh driven
to be a trumped up white dude you know
you probably still love him too you
wouldn't like the um the traitor aspect
of it but I'm sure you'd still love him
as your Offspring you know I mean Ted
Bundy's mom still loved him up until the
very end
so
lay in there what are you gonna do that
parental love is hard to break
um but let's get back to the Civil War
that's happening inside the Republican
party because it is magnificent
they again the plot line Slips Away from
the son of a [__] every single time
we talked yesterday extensively about
how all like the Bud Light thing where
they're gonna cancel Bud Light because
it put rainbows on its cans which it did
not didn't put rainbows on its scans or
whatever the hell they claim are there
the queer beer or the queen of beers
whatever the [__] they're talking about
this these face plants
are the absolute [__]
Talent of the right
because
for for [__] days as we wondered and
we were trying to figure out in the
public
where these leaks came from what was the
motivation of them
it was like oh it's it's uh Biden is the
worst biting this and biting that Hunter
Biden's laptop the woke the woke
government I mean it was just every
[__] every buzzword they had they
were blaming these leaks on and wow
wouldn't you know
what do you know here it is
the same the same way with Tennessee as
we pointed out the other day they face
planted I'm going to show you I'm going
to show you some [__] video today
of Justin Jones absolutely Burning Down
the Tennessee House Republicans and then
I'm going to show you a [__] a
[__] tape of their Caucus meeting
where they can't even get it together
themselves they're terrified to be
called racist folks they're terrified of
it don't stop do not stop calling them
racist do not stop calling them bigots
do not stop calling them Nazis do not
stop calling them fascists keep going it
bothers them to the ever loving [__]
bigoted core that they have and the
reason why is because it's true right
it's the [__] truth
listen if someone came up to you and
called you a name that doesn't [__]
resemble you at all I don't care how
mean it is how disparaging it is if it
doesn't resemble you at all you wouldn't
get offended you'd be like what what the
[__] are you talking about what the [__]
are you talking about
how am I going to be offended by
something that doesn't even resemble
anything near me the reason why these
[__] white real America First
Christian nationalist Nazis are so
offended to be called these things is
because they are and they know that's
where their deep-seated hatred's coming
from they know they're legislating and
using using their power to promote
hatred they know it they [__] know it
and now they know that we know and now
that we know that they know that they
know that we know they're really in
[__] trouble here
because they don't want to be pinned up
as this yesterday I played you here's
another example yesterday I played you a
video in a Missouri State Hearing we're
a Missouri state senator named Mike Moon
not only did he defend his vote to make
sure 12 year olds could be married in
Missouri with parental consent and let's
be clear it's not about 12 year old boys
being married that ain't what it's about
they're not trying to marry on 12 year
old boys they're trying to marry [__]
little girls because they're [__]
pedophiles
and it pisses them off when we call them
that when they show their pedophilia
right out in the open because Mike moon
in this in this [__] hearing
he says I will listen I know 12 year
olds have been married and they're still
married he's defending it
defending it
it goes viral online people are now on
to him that he's a [__] pedophile I
would say that the authorities need to
check this motherfucker's laptop is what
they need to do where the hell is the
Missouri State Highway Patrol where's
the feds checking Mike moons
I mean we need to call upon the doj to
make sure that Mike Moon's laptop
doesn't have cocaine hookers or other
stuff on it let's be let's be clear
but Mike moon has to make a videotape to
defend his pedophilia with Bible verses
I'm not [__] you
and and he invokes the Bible of Christ
being crucified of his reasoning why he
wants 12 year olds to be married what
the [__]
folks listen liberals aren't running
around the country trying to find using
the Bible trying to justify
their [__] shortcomings
we're not projecting our problems onto
other people what we're saying is hey we
like rights Liberty Freedom Choice leave
everyone the [__] alone
stop with the you problems if you got a
you problem about someone's sexuality or
something that's a [__] you problem
if you got a you problem about how
someone wants to dress or dye their hair
or what where they want to live or how
they want to live that's a [__] you
problem take your you problem and stick
them straight up your ass
America's sick of it
but they continue continue to project
and in this in this [__] tape that
was acquired by Justin and Tennessee
holler and was posted online by him
this recording of This Caucus meeting oh
my God
I mean some of the [__] that they're
saying in this meeting is exactly what
you would think they would say
it's not it's not like whoa
groundbreaking holy [__] the racists are
sitting around in a mean going I don't
like being called the racist because I
am
there's at one point in this tape in
this tape
in the Tennessee Republican caucus now
again this is all part of this the
pudding fingers Civil War folks I know
it doesn't feel like the thumbnail of
Ron DeSantis and Donald Trump
drawing a wedge issue with the [__]
pudding fingers has nothing to do with
this Caucus meeting in Tennessee but it
has every thing to do with it
everything to do with it Jesus Christ
they bring up Trump in this [__] in
this [__] audio they're like oh well
this is it's just like when Donald Trump
is being persecuted by indictments
they want to be oppressed so [__] bad
these these [__] trumped-up white
dudes are so desperate to be oppressed
it's [__] laughable
but they're like ah we're we're being
oppressed because we're being called
bigots and racist
and they go after each other because
there's one in particular Republican in
Tennessee that when Gloria Johnson when
Gloria Johnson's vote came up he voted
the opposite way he told them he would
vote that's why they were short one vote
to get rid of her
and they're mad at him because he turned
his vote
to make sure that the white woman wasn't
expelled because she wasn't as loud as
the black dudes I'm not kidding you in
the tape he said she wasn't she didn't
say anything they were the ones who were
being loud she just walked with them she
was just walking with them while white
that's not a crime being loud wild black
that's a crime literally and and the
entire caucus like you son of a [__]
you hung us out to dry you made us
appear to be the racist we are I'm not
kidding you I mean not in so many words
that's that's the [__] mood of the
room in this recording
but folks this is the puddin finger
Civil War that we should be encouraging
this is the this is this is the fire we
should be pouring gasoline on they're
losing the [__] plot
they do every time and the reason why is
because their entire existence is built
around a mountain of lies all of it it's
a mountain of Lies there aren't there
aren't children
with their bodies being mutilated to
turn them from a man to a woman or a
woman to a man that doesn't exist your
[__] Liars it's a [__] lie people
aren't going into opposite bathrooms so
they can sexually assault someone and
change their entire look their entire
gender their entire wardrobe take
hormones are you kidding me you're
telling me adult men are transitioning a
woman just so they can go into a
bathroom get the [__] out of here I'll
show you a hundred [__] Christian
priests that are [__] molesting
people out in the open in their churches
they don't have to go they don't even go
in the bathroom to do it
[__] out of here with that nonsense
lies
they tell you there's porno and books in
schools they're banning books with
pictures of the Statue of David in it
calling it pornography get the [__] out
of here with that [__] it's a lie
they're lying to you
it's all [__] lies CRT d-e-i wokism
it's all [__] lies
all of it full stop period and that's
why they can't get a grip on it that's
why they lose the plot line every single
time because once they stumble and base
plant on the [__] truth like they did
with Bud Light in the beer
they had a natural visceral reaction
to Dylan Mulvaney printing her face on a
beer can
for a special order for herself
they took that as Bud Light is doing a
marketing campaign to to make children
gay and to make you gay
as if beer or drinking anything anywhere
everyone knows this hey hey you [__]
idiots listen up you're you're born that
way you dumb [__]
it's it's not complicated to understand
you don't turn someone gay with a beer
you don't drink a beer and be gay
wow and if you really are scared that if
you drink something it turns you gay or
will turn or automatically turn your
children gay you are really insecure
about your sexuality it's it's
projecting hard but they face planted on
the beer and the reason why is because
they have these stupid [__] reactions
to anything and everything that they see
is a threat to their whiteness that's
right it's a threat to their straight
CIS white male wrinkly up ball sack
fragile manga trumped up existence
and privilege they see it as a threat
and let me tell you something when the
oppressed or when the oppressors see the
oppressed want equality they feel like
they're having their privilege Stripped
Away in its oppression and they're
desperate they're desperate to be
oppressed and the more desperate they
get the more mistakes like this they're
gonna make folks
like the Bud Light or Tennessee or Ronda
santis deciding to go to Ohio to stand
in front of [__] 20 people that
barely clap for him when he repeats the
word woke over and over and over again
while leaving his [__] Floridians
underwater I wanted to say hung out to
dry but they're not dry they're wet as
[__] it's flooded down there in Fort
Lauderdale
so what again let's not take the shovel
out of their hands let's encourage it
because frankly this ad that I'm going
to show you later
that Trump Trump's campaign
has put out of Ron DeSantis dipping his
three fingers
into a cup of chocolate pudding and
eating the pudding off his fingers
also have to do
come the general election is start
playing these ads
that's it look what they did look look
what they're saying about each other
what do you want me to do
this is really I mean if you want to get
it down to a sports ball analogy
think of it this way we're already going
to the championship baby the Liberals we
have won and we are going to the
championship game which is the general
election in 2024. alls we have to do is
stand back
and watch the playoff game for our
opponents okay
one team is the worst team in history on
their [__] best day and our worst day
we will beat them because they're
[__] lunatics they're Maniacs they
have half a team half the team ain't
even interested they're over there
bitching about beer and woke M Ms right
they're not even focused in on the game
and frankly they're playing basketball
not football and it looks a little crazy
on the field they're the lunatics the
other team that they're gonna play in
the playoffs to come play us for the
championship
this [__] team probably couldn't beat
us on their [__] best day in our
worst day but I'll tell you what the
lunatics are gonna do they're gonna
literally literally kneecap the other
team feed them poison put poison in
their food poison in their Gatorade
they're gonna make sure to poison them
so much that they're too sick to even
play them in the [__] playoff game
and I'm sure I'm sure it will affect him
for the championship game when they play
us and let me tell you something are we
gonna stand back and go hey that's bad
sportsmanship oh man that's bad form for
that playoff oh my God we we want to
play a team that's that's ready to go we
want good competition no no we want to
stop the ever loving [__] out of that
team in the championship
we want that ring on our finger before
the game begins
so let them play this playoff let them
kill each other politically in the
Republican primary [__] them
keep going Republicans in Tennessee and
Cameron Sexton keep going keep doing
what you're doing
it's beautiful Ron DeSantis keep leaving
your state as Governor when the law
states that you can't run for president
because you're a sitting Governor keep
leaving your state keep doing that man
that's going to help us a lot keep
eating pudding with your three [__]
fingers Donald Trump keep making videos
that shows that you're all in with white
supremacy keep doing it man keep keep
killing yourself when you're [__]
trying to obstruct Justice whether it's
you or your buddy Jim Jordan Congress
keep going keep doing it don't stop
you're only helping us make sure that
not only we secure the White House in
2024 we add Senate seats we take back
the House of Representatives we take
some State houses we take governorships
attorney generals I'm telling you folks
City councils all the way down to the
God damn woke ass dog catcher
let's do this folks let's engage in our
democracy let's kick some fascist ass in
2024 and it starts today Friday here on
the Tony Michaels podcast you know what
day that is that is the day that we do
bone hand of the week
and here's how you vote for bone and the
week don't forget to subscribe right
here on YouTube right here on the Tony
Michaels podcast you can vote every
single week on the YouTube channel on
the community tab you can also vote on
Twitter at Tony Michaels pot for the
time being tell Elon completely destroys
Twitter it's supposed to be tomorrow
he's supposed to change the polls on
Twitter we'll see if it happens I don't
know who the [__] knows with this guy
but download every single episode of the
Tony Michaels podcast on Apple Spotify
Google it's free 99 over there you get a
five finger discount over on Apple's
Spotify and Google of the audio version
of the Tony Michaels podcast so don't
don't refuse that offer also follow us
on Facebook at the Tony Michaels and if
you can if you got an Amazon Prime
account do me a favor link your Amazon
Prime account to a Twitch account and
you get one free subscription on Twitch
with your Amazon Prime account give us
that free subscription doesn't cost you
a single nickel if you're an Amazon
Prime user
and we'll get a couple bucks a month
from Amazon that's right Amazon pays us
I get Jeff bezos's money if you go link
the two also don't forget if you've
already done this you have to go in and
renew it every month
just go in say I'm gonna give this
month's subscription to them and then
they give us the money
few people have dropped off there
because they don't know that you have to
renew so you have to renew the
subscription every month it just every
month going reading the subscription
boom you're good you're good to go
I want to thank you also yesterday
um we broadcast in a hide and seek
Thursday
on Gabe Sanchez's YouTube channel you
guys came through it was crazy you are
the best you are the best audience in
the world you guys the whole entire
audience follows over to Gabe's Channel
and I think I think that video
you bastards I think that video has more
views on his channel than what we
normally get here that's incredible you
guys are great and [__] fantastic I
appreciate you so much you are the best
audience in the world and yesterday you
showed Gabe a ton of support on his
channel it was very important to me that
you came over and showed support on this
channel and maybe we'll get some more
creators or maybe we'll go to Gabe's
Channel once a month to play hide and
seek um you know I I'm open to all kinds
of ideas to have fun and because you are
you the [__] fan is the best chat fam
in the game I don't know if you know
that you are the best chat in the game
here on YouTube and really honestly
people are over on Facebook or twitch
there's great chat that happens over
there we pull them up all the time but
you should get into the YouTube chat
every once in a while and talk to the
[__] fam over on the YouTube channel
um it's incredible you guys are really
you guys are really incredible and our
audience is growing and growing every
single day we're adding more and more
people uh people who love me and people
who love to hate me we're adding them
every single day and with your help we
can grow this to be the number one
political show in the entire nation live
every single weekday Monday through
Friday noon Eastern 11 Central 9 Pacific
on YouTube Twitter twitch and Facebook
and don't forget this weekend I want to
make an announcement here this weekend
I'm gonna do my patreon party that's
right we're gonna have a big Zoom
meeting where everyone can attend on
Sunday I believe I'm gonna do it at
Seven Central
7 PM Central we'll go for a couple hours
probably
we're gonna do karaoke I'm going to show
you some of my favorite Comedy clips I
think uh you guys can talk to me and ask
me questions uh you can comment so make
sure to go to patreon.com the Tony
Michaels and sign up for patreon because
everyone who has a who is on patreon
will get an opportunity to come to the
patreon party this Sunday again it'll be
on patreon it's patreon.com D Tony
Michaels or just go to
thetonymichaels.com and hit the patreon
button you can join patreon for as
little as five dollars a month and that
will get you a ticket this weekend to
the very first patreon party very first
one
very first one and and again there's
some people on patreon that are like how
is this gonna work I'm like I'm not
really sure yet
I'm not that you guys think I like know
Tech and stuff that's Gabe Sanchez's
game okay that's why we have Gabe
Sanchez here as an executive producer
because he's he's knows more about the
tech so I know it seems a little crazy
but you can have bear with me on Sunday
we're gonna get it together I'll have
plenty of time
um once we get in the room and we get it
going
um but we we will have it on Sunday so
if you want to join the patreon party on
Sunday it's patreon.com
Michaels or go to
patreon.commichaels or
thetonymichaels.com and click the
patreon link you're not going to want to
miss the very first one it's likely to
be the greatest one
probably more than likely
I'm just saying it'll probably be the
hilarity of me not knowing what the hell
I'm doing is probably what'll be the
best part Frankly Speaking so make sure
to go to the Tony michaels.com and
follow us on all the social media and
make sure do not forget to subscribe to
the Tony Michaels podcast right here on
YouTube thank you gangs for all your
support this week and thank you for
following me over to Gabe's Channel it
means a lot to him it means a lot to me
it really truly does everyone stick
around we'll be right back right after
this
what the [__] is wrong with you people
it's a rhetorical question at best
we'll be right back on the Tony Michaels
podcast
[Music]
letters from the trucker Convoy
there's Tammy by the time we reach DC
wait was 50 strong in number some
patriots ran out of gas along the way
we got plenty of Slam gems skull
near run out of Natty light
hope it don't rain tomorrow so we can
Circle the city again
Bob
dear Bob I'm fixing to send you some
more of them Doritos you like the red
bag not the live love and blue one
in your absence I discovered a rash on
my neck and no it ain't no hickey and I
even seen my cousin Brody in ages
stay strong wipe your ass at least once
a day
yours Tammy
[__] um
we're back to the Tony Michaels podcast
foreign
[Music]
end of the week we're gonna have Gabe
Sanchez join us for bonehead but before
that I want to show you a few of these
um Clips out of Tennessee
um here is brother brother Jones Justin
Jones you know he was just receded we've
been covering this
um to the Tennessee House of
Representatives he's the representative
and one of the representatives that
represents Nashville
and yesterday Cameron Sexton because he
can't not now have Justin Jones or
Justin Pearson speak on the floor they
have to do it now right
again they [__] face plant every time
if they just would not have expelled
Justin Jones or Justin Pearson
and tried to expel Gloria Johnson
from the Tennessee house
they would still be cutting their mics
and not allowing them to speak right no
air time no time at all there would be
no national news they wouldn't be doing
interviews they wouldn't be propelling
themselves to be superstars in the
Democratic movement
they wouldn't be propelling themselves
to be icons in the civil rights movement
in the New Age Civil Rights Movement
they just wouldn't be
but the Republicans couldn't help
themselves
they had they had to go full races
that's what they had to do
they had to
so the Tennessee three get propelled
to have a huge amplification
not just on social media but on national
news on cable news on on the internet in
general
but now they have to allow them to speak
on the floor and the reason why is
because if they don't allow them to
speak
this this onslaught of everyone knowing
their [__] racist is going to keep
going
keep going and going and going and going
it's not gonna stop
so they have to allow them to talk
and the craziest part is is every viral
every video that happens with these with
these two speaking in the chamber goes
viral
here here's an example here is um you
see Justin Pearson here in the
background observing uh representative
Justin Jones
speaking here but listen to The Exchange
that Justin Jones has with a republican
man
member of the House listen to this
maybe President Reagan do you believe
that it is it is racist to prohibit
Concepts on systemic racism in the
history of America
Jim Reagan thank you Mr Speaker once
again my belief is in God I settle other
things with facts and data the fact of
the matter is Sir this bill is not
racist it is not unconstitutional
representative Jones we keep bringing up
God but God says in Isaiah 10 woe to
those who pass unjust laws that hurt the
poor and Rob them of their rights and so
stop using God to justify your bigotry
stop using God to justify hatred and
racism stop using God
[Music]
you were out of order representative
I love it listen here's what I said on
Twitter I said get out of order and stay
out of order [__] get out of
order and stay at orders now this is so
hilarious
that this representative Ray Reagan or
Reagan or Reagan whatever his name is
some old wrinkly white ball sag did you
see that invokes God and religion Jesus
Christianity why why in the [__]
would would you bring
a [__] Bible verse to a fight you
can't win with brother Jones
Justin Jones knows the Bible front and
back [__] I don't know how many
times he has to do this to prove to
these idiots that they should not should
not use God or the Bible in any way
shape or form as an argument to direct
at Justin Jones holy [__] absolutely
destroys him pulls pulls the Bible verse
out of nowhere right
it's crazy it's absolutely crazy
how the Tennessee House of
Representatives
has crumbled because of their own
actions watch this tape this is um this
is from Justin and canoe um from the
Tennessee holler uh let me let me give
credit for this I don't want to [__] my
computer's running Jesus Christ
must be the Deep State my computer's
running slow
um here's here's Justin's post uh again
Justin is the founder of Tennessee
holler so give Tennessee holler uh a
follow but also give Justin a follow
here but this is the uh the the now it's
audio it's audio
um and it's it's got the images of the
representatives on it now I want to fast
forward to one part here
because I it's it's 10 minutes long and
you should really go um listen to this
we want to go right
um where is it
So I listened to this several times last
night of course it's not gonna what the
[__] man my goddamn internet I swear
I don't know what to tell you
I think it's somewhere about right here
let's let's listen in on a little bit of
this
of course it's not gonna load
you got to be [__] me
ridiculous absolutely ridiculous
okay maybe maybe it'll go now here we go
I think now
more than ever everyone should recognize
that Democrats are not our friends
Democrats are not our friends
[Music]
did you hear that they're being called
racist they're being called names God
damn hey Dustin hey Dustin did you hear
that they're scared of names oh them
pansies dusting them pansies are scared
of names oh there's no dear Evan name
why are they calling us racist biggest
[__] out of here they were calling you
racism biggest because you are why not
Embrace this look your predecessors out
there and during the first Civil Rights
Movement embraced racism they were like
segregation and segregation now
segregation forever I mean just [__]
own it you [__] ass [__] just own it
why why are you running away from it why
are you such snowflakes
Jesus Christ Hitler would be so
disappointed in you nincompoop Nazis
such whiny little [__] [__] did
the Nazis of 1930s Germany whine this
much about being called racist and
fascist and Nazis did they whine this
much [__] out of here man you bunch of
goddamn [__] let's continue to listen
to this snowflake [__]
and for the last three days
oh he's never been called a racist oh
poor Zachary never been called a racist
in his life I've never had someone
challenge me and my racism and you know
what I've been able to be a bigot and a
racist my entire white existence and no
one has ever ever ever in public called
me a racist and now now that I showed my
racism for the entire world to see
they're calling me a racist what a bunch
of God damn [__]
am I am I off my rocker here this is a
private meeting I don't know if you know
this this is a private meeting between
Republicans only someone's recording
this [__] and leaked it out probably
because they were like Jesus Christ this
is well this is horrible the all these
[__] need to go
but they blame they blame this all on
just a few people who changed their vote
at the last minute on Gloria Johnson
because we all know that when there was
three votes to expel they voted to expel
the two black men but did not expel the
white woman by one vote
one vote is all it was
to keep Gloria Johnson and not expel her
and they blame it on this Barrett guy
let me see if I can get uh fast forward
to this Barrett game let me see
and the Zachary here we go the Zachary
this representative Zachary who's
whining about someone calling him or no
one's ever called me a racist
pointed out
what a dumb [__] but he blames he blames
people
pointing out his races in public because
they showed their racism for the whole
world to see on Barrett representative
Barrett he's a republican too he he's
one of the ones that changes vote on
Gloria Johnson the last minute listen to
this
straight up team
you hung this out to dry what you did
was you changed your vote on Gloria
Johnson because she's white and you
showed the world that we were racist you
showed them what we were doing you hung
us out to dry
he gets to vote how he wants to vote and
he voted the way that you would vote
anyways to keep the white woman [__] out
of here with this nonsense they go on
and on and on and here's one of the
arguments that Barrett makes
Barrett says well Cameron Sexton didn't
give me the speaker didn't give me the
time to ask the questions that I wanted
to ask to make the case that Gloria
Johnson is one of them that's basically
what he says he's one she was one of
them she wasn't an outlier but the other
the other ones were like no no no she
was just a white woman who walked to the
well with the black guys who were loud
and obnoxious and uppity she wasn't
uppity she was just walking with them
while white she wasn't being loud while
black I mean it's something else to
listen to this and it's 10 minutes long
and you really should go listen to this
[__] hilarious
it's it's hilarious because they they
they're telling on themselves here and
they don't even know it like they're
trying to say here's what they're trying
to say they're trying to say we had to
expel the white woman so we didn't look
racist
listen if you if your objective was to
make sure that the white woman got
expelled so you didn't appear to be
racist you're [__] racist
you [__] bone-headed [__] how don't
you see this you're like oh you hung us
out to dry and made us look like race
the racist that we are because you kept
the white woman we had to expel her too
to make sure people didn't know we were
racist and the reason why we actually
wanted to expel Justin Jones and Justin
Pearson you [__]
what the [__] is wrong with these people
I know I know it's right they're fascist
they're [__] bigots they only have a
place of hate that they exert their
power that is it and it's not just
Tennessee folks it's the entire
Republican party all of them every
single one of them I don't give a [__] I
don't care what a position they hold I
don't care if it's city council School
Board I don't give a [__] if it's a
state legislator a governor an attorney
general I don't give a [__] if it's a
United States Congressman I don't give a
[__] if it's a senator or someone who
wants to be the president United States
the only thing they use their power for
is to push their hatred that's it
full stop period that's all they're
doing everywhere and anywhere they have
power is exert their power for hatred
that's it
and they're mad that we're on to them
they're mad that gen Z isn't gonna
[__] stand back and take this [__]
they're mad that social media and the
internet is exposing them they're mad
when the whole world sees their bigotry
and they get called racist they it
really hurts their [__] feelings when
they get called the races that they are
cause look it wouldn't [__] offend
you if you weren't a racist and someone
called you a racist you would probably
laugh in their [__] face right your
actions speak louder than words dummy
so if you're not a racist stop being one
just stop doing racist [__] stop doing
it just stop [__] doing it stop
passing bills that are racist stop
passing bills that are transphobic stop
passing bills that are homophobic stop
hating on [__] stop hating
Americans stop hating [__] other
human beings stop it that will help
that will help in your quest of people
not calling you [__] names that you
don't like to be called you goddamn
[__] ass [__]
and I'm talking to you Tennessee how
House of Representatives in this Caucus
meeting but more than anything I'm just
talking to anyone with a r behind their
name
any politician any former elected
politician anyone who wants to be
elected as a republican politician I'm
talking to you let me see if I can find
this one part that is um that's very
important because I believe it's
um it's Lambert that says this let me
see if I can find it here
now of course it's too long uh one of
the representatives in this tape at the
very end his name is Lambert says this
this is the quote
this is the quote this is there this is
their [__] whole
philosophy folks their whole philosophy
right now is this is it in a nutshell
for the Republican Party listen to this
this is the quote you gotta do what's
right
even if you think it might be wrong
I'm not [__] you he [__] says
this out loud in this meeting to these
other Republicans says it out loud the
quiet part they're in a room they don't
think anyone's gonna [__] know he
says you gotta do what's right even if
you think it might be wrong
holy [__]
so if you think something's wrong if you
feel deep down inside your gut that this
is wrong we shouldn't do this this is
gross
doesn't matter do it anyways
because it's right it's right wing
what is all right
and it's right to hate that's their
that's their MO that's it
what are you gonna do
so [__] them [__] them listen I'm I'm
not gonna get all bent out of shape and
be like oh my God we need to expel all
these members of the Tennessee house and
no there's going to be elections folks
that's what elections are for we don't
need to expel the Tennessee Republicans
by the way you're not going to expel
them anyways Cameron Sexton that pile of
[__] is the speaker of the house and
besides they're rushing to close their
session because of this
did you hear that the Tennessee
legislator is rushing to close their
session they they sent their members
home uh are going to send them home over
the weekend and telling them pack your
bags for like 12 [__] days
because we're gonna do everything we can
to finish this [__] out because we're
tired of the cameras we're tired of
people asking us questions we're tired
of looking like the racists that we are
we're tired of having to be called
bigots like we are we don't want it
anymore it's bad for our image and it's
bad when they're asking questions so we
want to end this session and get the
[__] out of here and move on get the
hell out of here get the hell out of
town so no one can answers questions or
hold us accountable
they're running away of course they are
of course they are
it's not it's not hard to understand
this
that they would be that they would be
running from these things
oh boy oh boy
so in Tennessee
um there's gonna be heavy campaigning I
would imagine and I would imagine that
because of the shortcomings of the
Republican party there they're going to
keep face planting here it's not going
to stop base planning hell I showed you
face planning in Nashville it wasn't
even the Republican party of Tennessee
yesterday or the day before when was it
when we showed the Kid Rock bar thing
where Kid Rock he hates Bud Light and
John Rich hates Bud Light but they got
Bud Light Anheuser-Busch
at their bars
[__]
telling just
just I'm I I am excited that the
Republicans are at face plant city and
they're not gonna go away from face
plant city they're just not they're just
not and you know
um someone posted this video online
today Gabe Sanchez I don't know if
you've seen this video before but it
really plays out exactly what's
happening to the Republican party right
now not just in Tennessee but I mean
this has done it now with the flooding
in Fort Lauderdale where he went to Ohio
and wait he didn't he didn't when he was
I want to know when he was in Ohio did
he bring the white boots or not I don't
know well I mean he he spoke in front of
tens of white people and he said woke he
said woke as many times as he possibly
could and they barely clapped for him I
don't know do you think Jeb Bush do you
think like the flooding was like the
repercussions of sane woke so many times
like he invoked Gods like yeah like like
you know how like when you stand in the
mirror and you're like Beetlejuice
Beetlejuice I won't say the third time
because I'm not trying to bring that on
the show right now
you're saying you're way you're saying
you're saying that woke storm clouds
heard Ron DeSantis knocking on wokeism
and these woke lives are like I'm gonna
show you [__] do you think he'll go to
Fort Lauderdale and be like this is why
we need to get rid of wokism in the
states I think Florida I think he's all
this water is woke I think what he'll
probably say is we need to ban this
water we need to ban and it's not just
water we need to ban the climate we need
to bring in Mother Nature right because
she's woke she is she's like awoke she
is so woke
that she was like look I'm gonna flood
this you know State whatever he's like
[__] that [__] I'm not there but I think
if I think if he's like woke woke and
then says woke another time like right
in succession of it then you know Mother
Nature's like oh I'll show you woke and
then cause the flooding and then he was
like and then he ran away right do you
think that he stands in front of the
mirror each morning and he's practicing
saying the word he's like woke
I think
what he says
those are those are different times
that's when he comes back home like
after after a travel out right he's like
oh and he's like I'm I'm worthy I am
worthy like he's just like saying to
himself these affirmations of being like
I am totally deserving of the good
things that come to me right which is
really all the bad things that company
but I think he stands in front of the
mirror and he looks deep deep deep into
the emptiness of his soul and he says to
himself
what where work
like he tries out different ways to say
it right and then and I think in
addition to that but he settled on one
he's got one yeah he's got one but I
think also I think he also practices the
ability to say his name because we know
that he's changed his name how he
pronounced it he was like it was d
stands DeSantis dies and then it went
from it went from d santis right this d
santis d santis d santis to DeSantis
right he doesn't he didn't do scientist
because he says right well he sounds
like he's from Missouri when he says
just Santas because that's I mean that's
how I said DeSantis even if it's a d we
say yeah
because like if there's an a in a word
sometimes there's an R after it even
though you don't know it like Worship
You Gotta wash your clothes there is
that orange toilet did you know that
toilet you know
you get close to St Louis and there is a
[__] orange yeah just circling the
drain is what he's doing yeah toilet
it's a toy toilet can you get your ass
on the toilet yeah get off the toilet
with you yeah I mean maybe that's what
they tell Rhonda Santa so I get your ass
off the toilet right you know like do
something I know well and and you know
I I have to say that like Fort
Lauderdale was going to be flooded no
matter if Ron DeSantis was governor or
Charlie Christian whoever was going to
be Governor it was going to be flooded
right and it doesn't matter who runs the
city or doesn't run the city like Fort
Lauderdale is going to get flooded right
this is just events that are out of our
control right now and the reason why is
because we don't we're not doing the
things that we should do to try to
prevent some of these storms from
happening now like I don't know you know
climate change and paying attention but
you know we can debate that all day long
but the fact of the matter is is Fort
Lauderdale is flooded now will Ron
DeSantis go there because it's more of a
heavily Democratic area I don't know I
don't know if he'll go there I don't
know if he'll pay attention to this I
have no idea but I I am I am sure of one
thing is that to get votes he'll try
secretly because he's secretly passed an
abortion ban yesterday did you see this
yeah it's like a six-week man don't call
it a six-week band call it an abortion
ban they're banning Health Care here for
women in Florida they're banning Health
Care for Women in Florida and he signs
this bill in private right yeah of
course why would he sign it in public
just like he signed the open carry law
with just the NRA members just the NRA
people the [__] lobbyists in the room
like yeah why would he ever involve the
people uh that elected him no yeah I
mean like well I'm just saying like the
people that are paying him right he's
not going to do it anywhere else right
or with anyone else where he doesn't
feel comfortable and protected in his
little bubble that'll tell him no Ron
you don't eat pudding with three fingers
no Ron you are worthy no Ron they're
wrong and you're right you can be
president and we're going to help you
repeal the law that says that you have
to retire if you decide to run so hey
don't worry we're gonna pull you up by
your little white rain boots and we're
gonna we're gonna help you out and we're
gonna make sure that you're protected so
you can you be in the room here you be
in the room with a bunch of white men
and white women when you're signing this
law and and or this bill into law when
you're taking away rights of other women
right or taking away the safety of
Floridians by saying yeah anyone can
have a gun yeah [__] it why not right
where are you where you're at and no and
no woman can have health care can't do
that guns have more more [__] rights
over babies bodies right that's what
they say hashtag guns over baby watch
this commercial
the [__] pudding camera have you
watched it yeah yeah when you sent it to
me this morning I watched it I was like
God damn I mean you know I was like this
the the beer commercial that we watched
yesterday had a real had a real satire
parody Vibe right they didn't know it
it's again it's a face plant into it
yeah but this this [__] commercial
I'm like man Gabe Sanchez totally could
have wrote this commercial I know
there's a part of me there's a part of
me
where and I don't know I'll do it so
I'll just say it on the show right now
but after watching that commercial and
honestly after talking more about the
affirmations just moments ago there was
an idea that basically would have me eat
and I haven't had chocolate pudding in a
very very long time it's been years
since I've had chocolate pudding what
yeah I don't know why do I need
chocolate pudding yeah so
my idea was that I would stand in front
of a mirror or something like that right
and then the camera would be off
off screen and I would basically be
crying and and this is your pudding and
this is your in many ways it this is
like an art piece right this is some
[__] this is some [__] weird art
that's happening right now where
basically there were two ideas okay one
was I'm in front of the mirror and the
camera's off and you see me crying and
eating pudding and I'm telling myself
that I am worthy and I am deserving of
all these things that happen right the
other idea is I don't know if you
remember
um
there is an old video that was done by
it was recreated by Macaulay Culkin and
it was originally done by um
uh why am I looking at his name he ate
uh uh Burger King
um
uh
he's an artist God damn it why am I
playing on my neighbor there we go Andy
Warhol okay there's a video of Andy
Warhol eating a burger and that's all
that it is right he opens it up he eats
the burger boom boom Macaulay Culkin did
a recreation of that for his band called
Pizza underground years ago years ago
okay and so my piece would be called
putting underground and it would just be
me
slowly eating pudding and the thing is
the way that the video goes there's no
words it's just eating and looking
straight into it like ASMR like
like kind of kind of all you would hear
like this I mean like you you see the
unwrapy like violin music
I don't think there's any let me see no
crying violins or anything because the
thing is he did it as a uh well
obviously I'm just saying I was trying
to be creative here damn it no I know I
know but I'm not trying to I'm not
trying to modify the original oh you
just want to to parody it yeah yeah
because all that that's all that it is
right there's no need you know people
would know oh that's this that's this
that I don't need to I don't need to um
to make anything else about it because
the whole point was you were sitting
there it's it's this art piece right
you're sitting there and you're eating
this piece of food so originally it was
Burger King and then it was just a slice
of New York Pizza that came out of a
brown bag with Macaulay Culkin and then
mine would be opening up
uh so this is performance art this is
performance art as a joke obviously but
its performance art in the sense of like
this is what I'm doing so again I don't
know if I will actually do it but those
are the two ideas that I had based on uh
seeing Rhonda seeing that ad really I
was like wow they really went there with
the three fingers well you know it's
crazy it's like that that's what you do
when you're trying to throw up right
well you know we were talking about this
when the pudding fingers story first
came out right and we said on the show I
believe we can go back and look at the
tape
I keep saying tape like I'm in the 90s
like there's a [__] VH there is
there's a we have an interview
yeah every every day we have it recorded
on VHS because some people are like oh
look can you digitize this old VHS or
this high no word
VHS and digitized no we analog guys if
that's even a word uh we take it from we
take it from digital and then we have an
intern off in a closet somewhere and we
tell them hey I need you to record this
and so many times he's just filming from
the phone you know right of the of the
show on the computer and then takes that
phone version and then translates it
into a VHS quality you know when I say
like bootleg you know when I say um play
the tape
I feel like Dora Fey is like Boomer
Boomer like every dime my God damn
um so if we played the clip black back
when the putting fingers first started
we sat on the show we were like hey
Trump campaign Liz Harrington if you're
listening I'm almost sure of it we're
like you need to make this [__] ad
yeah and
boom here several weeks later here we
are we got because what we saw was he
was doing he didn't talk about it in his
little videos he makes from Mar-A-Lago
and he didn't talk about it in his
interview with Sean Hannity and we're
like man you're talking here's Morgan
asked Ron to say this about it and Ronda
Santa's laughed weirdly
you know he's like I didn't do it I
never did it yeah
he like looks off screen he's like get
the pudding away get there right
you'll hear us joke about this right
well I I'm almost sure of it because
every time we say something to the Trump
campaign they take our advice like every
single [__] time everything it's it's
almost like was it was this was this ad
was this ad uh a paid for by the Trump
Camp yeah Mike America great again Inc
so it's his okay which is weird his
superpac is incorporated not a anyways
it's really weird he's got obviously
he's laundering money through his
political campaign of how he structured
it and I'm sure he's going to get
[__] knocked for this he's now being
investigated for wire fraud for his
credit card fraud that he that he
[__] laid on his supporters in in the
December of 2020 when when he was like
no we won give me your money yeah here
click here and and you'll give five
dollars every just once yeah yeah wink
and perpetuity until you die you know
which which is the thing you can't do
like it's against law to do it the way
that you have to the way that it is done
is you have well one you have to explain
explain what happened because yeah yeah
so basically when somebody went on to uh
the you know the uh the election fraud
defense fund right that's what it was
which is an actual thing there's no fund
yeah
I mean it was revealed during the Jan
six I mean it was dumping into a bank
account but even in in after it happened
I made a video making fun of this right
after it was announced that he had this
fund I was like if we look at the ratio
or the percentage right now originally
it was 60 to the save America pack and
then 40 went to the RNC that's what they
said at the time that's what they said
at the time and the way that it breaks
down is you have uh you have to like he
said okay 60 40 right but the way that
it actually was is this the save America
pack can be used to pay off his his
personal his debts right right
exactly it's got millions in that he
used for his own personal debts and in
the RNC they can use it for whatever and
they can use it to pay off his own
personal debt right so when he says hey
it's going to be going to this defense
fund to fight election fraud it's not
actually going to that because they
don't have to actually show you where
the money's being used so that's the big
red flag right there but of course
people like oh yeah I'll you know donate
money okay now the the issue here which
is the fraud go to the fraud yeah the
fraud is that when you donated you were
like yeah I want to donate five or ten
or 20 bucks or whatever now there is a
way in which donations and payments work
where you have to opt in right you can't
opt out so you opt in to say yeah I want
to make this a monthly recurring
donation right that's the way that it
works and if you do happen to have that
you need to clearly state it has to show
it and you have to click a box right
when you say I pay right except you know
I want to pay I want to agree to this
you have to have right there opt-in and
not only that but you have to clearly
State this is going to be a monthly
recurring that you'll be charged on the
first of the month or whatever it is
right whatever the terms right so what
happened was Not only was it already
clicked but it wasn't near where you
would be like oh yeah I want to pay
right it was not shown anywhere near it
was somewhere else there was another
section that was below the fold where
this check and it was technically opt-in
Yeah so basically what happened is
people were like oh yeah 5 10 20 bucks
whatever or people were like 100 bucks
if they want to do it thinking it was
one time then what happened is every
month people started getting these
charges and then started realizing wait
I'm getting I'm getting this is a
monthly charge I'm being charged right
now by this thing can you imagine if you
if you went on there and you're like I
want to give this guy a thousand dollars
right oh yeah
let's say your credit card limit's like
14 Grand or something [__] and it took
like three or four months before you
know it your credit card bill is four or
five thousand which is what happened
which is why it's the biggest credit
card fraud ever yeah I'm gonna say this
again this Donald Trump's 2020 big line
campaign
is the biggest and most widespread
credit card fraud ever in the history of
credit cards there is no credit card
fraud that is larger than his I mean now
Jack Smith is investigating as wire
fraud yeah I mean the reason why is
because it's not because
um like vs our MasterCard allowed this
right he really scammed Visa Mastercard
here because what he did was he
programmed it two to [__] scam them
by opting people in yeah automatically
they programmed the actual shopping cart
to make sure that opted in because
whatever it was charged and that's the
and so what Tony's talking about here is
when you when you make a charge right
then then you say oh yeah I agree to
this right but if there are charges that
are not approved by you there's a whole
thing that happens right now because
a lot of times if you're like oh I
didn't approve that charge then the
credit card company has to say okay what
we're going to do is we're going to
cancel that card because they can't
cancel the recurring donation they can't
cancel this payment right what has to
happen is either you have to actively go
out and cancel it which is a your you
have to jump through a bunch of Hoops to
do it because that's how they make it
for Trump or any other scam if they're
like oh yeah you can cancel but like you
got to call this number and you got to
do this thing you're going to fill this
form and do this so what happened what
ends up happening is that these credit
card companies they say oh well the only
thing we can do to actually stop this
payment is to kill the credit card so
now we've got to kill the credit card
and we gotta issue a new credit card so
all these people who have these
donations now have to have new cards
issued and then the actual credit card
companies then the processor the
processor have to look at the debts now
that are owed because they're like well
I didn't approve this purchase well now
that credit card has to you know pay
back the person who donated right who
was who had money stolen from them and
they say oh well you didn't approve this
okay we will reimburse you this money
which means now the bank was given money
or the Trump campaign was given money by
the the donor right and the donor didn't
approve it so the bank says [__] well
now we got to go out of pocket to pay
back the donor even though that credit
cards are just you know it credit is
made up money let's just call what it is
but
they were they were all monies made up
yeah yeah yeah right but you know the
the credit card company right now the
bank is now in [__] because they have
money that they were told they were
gonna get right and they had to cover
the transaction fee the processing fee
and then they also now have to say well
[__] now we got to put money
from what you said you were going to owe
us or that we're going to be owed to
back into your account to say you
actually don't own it meanwhile Trump
campaign is like oh yeah man we're
flying high we've got the money we don't
care and we're not going to pay you back
so the people who got [__] over were
the banks which is like okay well you
know Banks can be ground a little bit
but also these consumers who were who
were defrauded by the Trump campaign
because they didn't know that they were
making a payment that was done on a
recurring basis and again like you might
not look at your finances for a month or
two months because you know it's
whatever you're like oh I'll pay my
credit card if it's automatically or you
know it's like five dollars every month
you probably wouldn't notice that
thinking like oh five dollars I bought a
pack of gum or a pack of cigarettes or
can you imagine if can you imagine if
one of these people had like because a
lot of home equity lines have like a
credit card processor attached to it
they used to give you like a checkbook
right home equity but sometimes they'll
give you a number like a debit number so
some of these people the FI the [__]
processor was processing out of their
[__] lines of credit on their
mortgage which doesn't have the same
protection as like a credit card with
Visa or Mastercard yeah so that's why
this is one of the biggest [__] bank
and wire frauds in the history what is
the biggest one yeah like as far as
money and transactions wise right it's
the largest it's the largest [__]
credit card fraud that has ever happened
and that's the other thing too is like
when you have a credit card right if
there's a if there's fraud or the uh uh
uh a charge that was not approved by you
the credit card company would say great
we'll bring we got you we'll cover it
we'll figure it out
what if it's debit because there's fraud
protection right exactly but a debit
card that's that's straight up just cash
and right count if that money's gone
that money's gone in very very very
rarely does a bank say okay we'll
actually pull money out of our own
Pockets well they they actually well a
lot of times the bank will recover your
will give you your funds when they
recover it right from the people who
took it right
um not from not from you know so I'm
sure I mean that's something that's
still going on right and so like these
people lost their money and I wouldn't
be surprised if some of the people that
gave the money then got charged uh you
know without approval on these recurring
charges then said oh you know what I'll
get more money I'm not I'm not I'm not
hurt or upset about it it's a common
mistake so the funny part is is that
like
but this Jack Smith investigation
everyone's like lock him up for the
documents because yesterday we watched
this well how do you say his name James
and Teresa to re test Texas what's this
this Traders terrorist traitor yeah yeah
James crater anyway the one that marjor
Taylor green is defending anyways
um yesterday he was arrested within the
hours of finding out who he was yeah he
was the leader he was like a shirt in
basketball shorts and they're like he
was outside on the porch reading mind
comp now I don't know that it's Minecon
but I'm just guessing I mean I mean you
can you can safely assume based on other
entries he's made online that it's
probably could be I don't know if it's a
signed copy well I mean they like signed
copies I mean you know they're a
customer loving billionaire Harlan Crow
I can't Harlan Hitler
Harlan Hitler I can't say if it was a
science day don't say derogatory things
here on the Tony Michaels vodkas it's
Harlan Hitler right all right
in the house that he was picked up at
wasn't the house oh I got it Harlan Pro
paid for oh I got more on that story
yeah that's great that I got something
this morning that you're gonna love Gabe
Sanchez I don't even know if you've seen
it yet um Margie points out hello
sparklers welcome to all the sparklers
there must be a lot of sparklers in the
in the Chant today
um hey do you have I've got I've got the
um the main tile and the winter tile but
do you have the rest of them if you put
them in the drive oh yeah then we'll
we'll go to um bonehead of the week
um but well I want to show you one video
here and this really this video
it's kind of a lesson to manga and
really honestly if they would just watch
this video a couple times and really
understand
how these things work they would be much
much better off
um a lot of people have seen this video
but I think it's worth showing seeing
that we're seeing a lot of face planting
from manga right now let's let's go
ahead and review this for them for the
haters here who love to come hate watch
let me show them something let's talk
about how we can find out and how much
we can find out and what it takes to get
there
so first
we have as much do we want to find out
so let's say in this case I want to find
out
at a level of seven okay so I find that
level on my graph and I come
horizontally to my gradient line where
it intersects with my gradient line I'm
going to come straight down to where it
intersects with my [__] around life that
there's gonna tell me how much I have to
[__] around to find out what I need to
find out see as you can see
the more you [__] around
the more you're gonna find out and also
if you stayed on here and you never [__]
around
you'll never find out so I hope this
lesson is helpful thank you
it's I mean look there's no clear
message and like life lesson than that
right there right like the ability to be
like look if we just follow the X the
x-axis you know down here and the y-axis
up here if we follow you know we meet up
we'll find out if you [__] around right
it's so incredible that you just watch
that get have you have You Have you
listened to the entire 10 minutes well
it's almost 10 minutes of audio from the
Tennessee house Republican caucus
meaning
they're calling yeah they're calling us
racist because we are and we don't like
that I've never and my entire white
existence I've never been called a
racist in public yeah
I mean like you can tell 100 I mean I
think I quote tweeted the Tennessee
holler and I was like dude Republicans
are scared and good they should be right
this is them this is them being scared
inside like Democrats aren't gonna help
us and they're the enemy and we're being
called racist and it wasn't racist now
it isn't being a good old boy and it's
like no you guys are being racist and
your [__] [__] it flopped you face
planted it [__] backfired on you
magnificently so you thought that you
could pull this fascist little little uh
little play here and what what heads up
oh look they come back voted back
unanimously safe safe and sound so if
you guys try to [__] around again you're
gonna find out I mean you're finding out
right now because they're being
investigated or they're planning to be
investigated the craziest part to me is
like if they would have just not acted
out on their hatred to get rid of these
members for for being loud in the well
for a matter of seconds
then number one we we would still not
really know who representative Jones and
representative Pearson are now the the
other thing the other thing is they
wouldn't have to afford them now time to
speak on the floor they have to now give
Jones and Pearson the microphone or they
really do because they're like I don't
want to be called race anymore so let
him speak like you people are dumb as
dog [__] I wouldn't be surprised if they
end up being like Oh well now we have to
make up for it and so we're gonna give
them the mic as many times as they want
which is like worse it may seem worse
yeah because it representative Pearson
and representative Jones are no dummies
they're not yeah yeah they're and
they're not and they're not going to
take your [__] laying down right they're
gonna come right after you and they're
gonna keep fighting it's obvious
otherwise these two Representatives
would have went ah we're just gonna go
home and you know I'll I'll sit on the
sidelines and try to gain my influence
on social media by sitting on the no
they got right back in the fight
immediately they're like
from the very vote of them getting
expelled out into the open hallway
they're like yeah we're not [__]
right taking this line down and the
thing is is that Tennessee the
Republicans did this for clout for their
bigoted ass base right and their bigoted
constituency that wants them to continue
this nonsense when they can just say
they're considering look if you don't
want to vote for us because we're not
big it's fine whatever but we're not
going to continue this [__] bigotry
we're going to do the work of the people
and Justin Jones and Justin Pearson they
don't go again they don't go be martyrs
and be on social media and gain a social
media following and give away their seat
no they get right back in the feet for
right back in the fight for their
constituents that they're representing
and that is the difference between
Democrats in this country right now and
Republicans as Democrats are interested
in actual democracy they're interested
in governing their International they're
interested in representing their
constituents the Republicans are not
they're not interested governing they're
not interested in representing their
constituents they are not interested in
anything that doesn't have to do with
anything but hate that's all they want
to have anything to do with and hatred
and I think you know to to the point
that we've definitely discussed this
since the moment it happened we're like
look they just the Republican party uh
with their own kind of uh naivete or
ignorance or whatever you want to call
it right they created National icons
well really International icons because
everyone's like hey what's going on in
Tennessee that's really [__] up right
um
and
you know I wouldn't doubt I don't doubt
that both of these both of these guys
Justin Pearson and Justin Jones like
would have found themselves on a
national stage at some point right and
then right absolutely in the next five
ten years absolutely probably no no
doubt about it but
in in a matter of days right the
Republican Party decided hey you know
what we're gonna do we're gonna help
platform you guys up and accelerate your
career in politics by putting your name
on the international stage right
and what they ended up doing was helping
them out right they hurt their own the
Republican Party hurt themselves they
[__] shot themselves like
you know like [__] plaxco like shot
himself with his own gun you know like
it's one of those moments where
it's just a it's a face plant or it's
really it's like in the cartoons when
the farmers in the yard and he like hits
hits the rake boom The Rake hits him in
the head then steps one boom boom hits
him in the right it's just like or I
think like Foghorn Leghorn does that
right like where he steps on the rake
and it hits him in the face I say I'll
say I'll say boom I'll say boom I'll say
boom like it's that over and over again
and every time they think hey look I'm
gonna turn this direction and do
something else but really when you like
pan out you realize that they're just in
the center point of a circle of of rakes
that are that are ready to be stepped on
oh dude they're professional rake
steppers like this Mike moon in Missouri
we watched this video yesterday of Mike
moon in it [__] hearing where I don't
know shit's being recorded and he he
justifies his vote to make sure 12 year
old girls because I listen they are not
voting for 12 year old boys to be
married that's not what they're [__]
doing they're talking about 12 year old
girls because they're like what little
boys shouldn't get married that would
that would that would hinder their
manhood later on in life they're talking
about 12 year old girls and what
happened was is it went [__] viral
this Senator Mike Moon a senator a state
senator from the state of Missouri and
this [__] had to get out in
front of the cameras and do this this is
a [__] video of him it's almost like
a hostage video but he uses he uses the
Bible I'm serious
I'm serious I'm serious the Missouri
Republican party is like hey man you got
to get out front of a [__] camera and
you got to figure out a way to make us
not look like better files man it's the
same freak out that the Tennessee
Republicans are having by appearing to
be the racist that they are that Mike
moon is appearing to be the pedophile he
probably [__] is yeah I mean the guy
let's I mean let's let's be honest with
ourselves here the fact that they talk
about it so frequently probably means
that the like the people who are talking
about it probably are privy to acts that
have been done either by someone else or
themselves
and they're like ah this is the first
thing that's on my mind I'm gonna talk
about how we should marry and it should
be okay to I know people who've married
12 year old it's like the fact that you
use that as like oh that's that's the
flex you're gonna have on the defense
the story that he tells in this have you
seen this video no I haven't seen this
video so this video I'm telling you when
you first when you when you hear his
Cadence when you hear how he's trying to
tell this story his breathing he's very
[__] nervous you can tell because
there's a lot at stake on this video and
the reason why is because they've had a
Caucus meeting like the like the the
audio we listen to in the Tennessee
caucus yeah they came together like what
the [__] are you doing why in the [__]
are you saying this [__] in an open
hearing when you're openly supporting
because almost every single [__]
Republican voted the way Mike Moon did
almost every [__] one of them voted
the way that Mike Moon did okay so when
Mike Moon says that in a hearing what
people hear is the entire Republican
party thinks that way and and they they
do because they want 12 year old girls
to be married not boys girls because
listen to the example that he gives in
this story which I don't know if it's
real honestly I I'm sure journalists are
going to try to chase this down and it's
going to be completely [__] bogus
they made this story up they've
manufactured this story so that he could
give this hostage video here but he he
uses the weirdest [__] stories in the
Bible to justify I mean there's so much
stuff in the Bible where where little
girls get married off the the older men
that he could use an example but he
can't use that example because that's a
horrible example from the book that they
so think is sacred so he uses Jesus
being crucified for some reason but
listen this is [__] weird watch this
as I contemplated the bill I was
reminded of a couple I've met years
before
when this couple was in their teens
actually pre-teens okay so there's the
first there's the first sense of a lie
when he's like in their teens I mean
actually pre-teens so what he means is
them being younger than 13. yeah because
what the [__] he's saying because I mean
pre-teen I I think it's I mean like the
only time I've ever heard preteen is 12
right right you're 11 or 12. yeah 11 or
12. I mean which lines up with this
whole like I know people who got married
or who [__] I want 12 year olds get
married right because that's what that's
literally what they said in the hearing
he voted for a bill that would give
parents consent to give away their 12
year olds hand in marriage and they're
not talking about boys that's not what
that's not what these [__] are
thinking of people trust me they're not
talking about button 12 year old boys
get married to 30 year old women so I
just not what's happening I just looked
it up and pre-teen actually isn't 10 to
12 which is even [__] worse whoa oh
[__] so so first he rakes steps on the
[__] on the words in the [__]
statement okay because teens actually
preaching no actually I mean like teens
like you could
teenagers you know you could say uh
maybe that's like well yeah right right
to maybe 17 right right you're like yeah
he's like no I'm talking about really
young children we're talking 10 right
what I mean I'm a pedophile I'm a
Bonafide pedophile so let's listen to
his justification of preteens let's
listen it took actions that resulted in
the girl becoming pregnant
foreign
okay so this is this is one of the best
parts he says he says they took actions
when they were in their pre-teens as a
result of this girl getting pregnant he
totally totally whitewashes the fact
that you gotta [__] to make a baby yeah
right like these what like what what
other action are you talking about
besides the actual action of
impregnation you know what you know what
I think it is they didn't have sex Tony
they didn't have sex because no one has
sex uh of course until they're married
right so maybe especially a little white
Christian nationalists two possibilities
here one is they got married at 10 11 12
because they were pre-teen and then they
they fornicated right right they had sex
and then she got pregnant or the other
possibility is that you know Immaculate
Conception and God was like yo oh here's
a baby and put it inside and that was
the action that was done oh [__] you
didn't know maybe you know what it could
be it could be that they that these
pre-teens these 10 11 and 12 year olds
they opened up a fertility lab in their
garage oh and they yeah that's probably
and they did artificial insemination in
the garage with the fertility lab I mean
10 11 12 year olds do this kind of stuff
all the time they take these actions all
the time yeah okay so this is duties
made me pregnant right right so this is
this is his claim so already the story
smells hold on I really like [__] hold
on uh quesadilla 79 the Holy Spirit ski
ski
[Laughter]
oh my god oh I'm telling you like we we
have like professional comedians in our
chats there's I mean I feel like there's
so much like everyone is in the chat in
ourselves like there's so much volume
like we'll set each other up the chat
will set themselves up we set the chat
up the chat sets us up it's just a bunch
of there's a lot of like right why the
hell do you think so many people come
here every day this and no pun intended
no pun intended not if you're talking
about maybe I am yeah maybe I don't know
let's let's finish with this bogus asked
I really think this story is bogus I
don't know let me hear it I want to hear
the whole thing
I know it doesn't feel like this point
that it can get better but it gets
better listen Okay the youngster's
parents decided to allow the children to
marry they weren't forced however
because they were not mature and could
not provide for themselves they grew up
with their families in different states
okay so so they're not mature they're
not mature but they were mature enough
the parents thought that they would
consent to the marriage because they
were mature enough you know to get
married right pre-teens sure enough to
have a baby right so you're mature
enough to hate hey little guy you have
to go nine that's right possibly more
months
through physical emotional uh you know
mental trauma right stress on your body
when you don't even understand what's
going on you now have to uh bear another
body inside of you when you're when
you're developing and then and then
there's a 12 year old boy in this story
too right because this 12 year old boy
is probably not around
this is what makes this is what makes
this all [__] and fake this is what
makes this all [__] and fake is that
there's a 12 year old boy because this
Mike Moon can't say there's a 25 year
old man who impregnated a 12 year old
girl and then the parents consented with
him and it was not a forced it was not a
forced marriage he can't say that [__]
because No One's Gonna believe that
[__] No One's Gonna believe that
[__] story that a 25 year old man
impregnated 12 year old girl and the
parents didn't force her to have a baby
and get [__] married to him they're
not gonna believe that [__] so he has to
make up a story where 12 year old and 12
year old are having a baby and then they
they get married not forced oh the
parents they loved each other and then
they moved they separated away the
parents consented for them to get
married and then separated them and they
lived in differences
[__] any sense
they made them get married but didn't
make them get married but then made them
divorce but didn't make them get
divorced
[__] phone prove it Mike Moon tell us
if you are they're adults now tell us
who they are you [__] if I had to
guess if this story is true and a little
girl from 10 to 12 was impregnated right
I would have to guess that it might be
the result of one of those other parents
right one of those other men right the
the men of the boy or another person and
that's the reason they [__] moved
away
right right like to be in a community
with a with a predator
I'm sure the reason that if this child
had a baby right because that's what she
is she's a child if this child had a
child
well that's why he says pre-teen tubes
that's called it's a Kim it's a baby man
it's a little baby ten years old that is
one year older than the babies
that died in Nashville at the Covenant
Elementary School just think about that
kids at an elementary school were
impregnating other kids at an inland
elementary school that's not how it
works right I mean like not saying that
it's not impossible but it's very
improbable well the other the other
thing here too about this story is he is
framing this story as the logical reason
of why he voted for 12 year olds to be
married under their my parents my
anecdotal story of some girls getting
one example is why this should be either
right it's right again it's ridiculous
but listen to his Jesus argument at the
end it gets even worse
after a number of years when the
children became adults and were able to
care for themselves they began to live
in oh my God the couple was still
married today so with this in mind and
because allowances for these extreme
exceptions were not included in the
language I voted against the bill
oh now now he's for extreme exceptions
Gabe Sanchez with this we
went about marrying a 12 year old girl
someone there there is Extreme
exceptions when it comes to her being
pregnant no exceptions none yeah yeah no
exceptions none it's it's almost like
it's almost like a bunch of privileged
white dudes
dictating what women and not just women
but little baby girls are gonna do and
what they're not gonna do it's almost
feels like that hey you know what would
be crazy if this whole story was just an
admission of guilt I I bet that's what
it is like I mean let's just think about
it right I mean he's like married to his
his cousin wife or Esther Grandma type
thing maybe yeah I don't I don't know
what's his name again
um Mike Moon he's he's from the south
part of the state so he's like Northern
Arkansas so it wouldn't be surprising if
this is right so like if I look at his
I'm not saying that he's we're still
we're still married today here that's
why I voted for the bill cause I'm
married a 12 year old four yeah his
spouse is Denise Moon they have five
children
yeah
um I'm trying to see what her age I'm
not saying that she's the one but there
is a part of me well but if he was the
12 year old and she was the 12 year old
then they'd be the same age right I'm
just saying
Theory right the way he's saying it the
way he's right
he's such a [__] bunny I don't know the
guy the fact that he's [__] doubling
down and is I can't I can't find well
you know the thing is I didn't find
anything about his wife though but just
look at the just look at this stop image
here right you got the American flag one
side you got that
easy on the old word there Jesus well I
mean like she I said she's older she's
older yeah she's as old as he is
probably they're not yeah they're not
they look comparable in age right I mean
he'll do a lot to you well see here's
the thing and I was gonna point that out
doesn't he look like he came out of a
wider movie right like he was I'm just
saying I'm just saying he's got that Sam
Elliott Look to Him yeah I mean look
here I sent you a photo this is him yeah
from his wedding day so we know so we
know at least it wasn't this wedding
that happened oh this is from his
website too yeah okay so so this isn't
this isn't projection no wow that's not
to say that he wasn't involved in
something and he said that he's got a I
gotta admit his stash got better with
time I'm just gonna I'm not gonna show
you a picture because I want to keep
showing the video here yeah yeah I did
stash got better with time he definitely
ends that Sam Elliott Look to Him like
this guy yeah is a character
look real nice like Sam right well
obviously obviously I'm not saying Sam
Elliott is anywhere near oh yeah yeah
this guy I'm just saying this guy's
trying to emulate how he looks is Right
Sam Elliott he's trying to copy Sam
Elliott yeah how he looks let's roll the
tape here Tony the BHA let's let's play
the video what do you think this feels
like it was scripted do you think he
practices or you think he's reading it
um what do you think you know that's a
good question I think uh I mean I don't
know I don't I I I would have to track
his out here I can watch closer okay
at the end here he kind of go if it is
scripted or if it is scripted he goes
off script but let's finish the story
and then he'll tell us his reason why
the Bible fits in
tragic circumstances such as these can
only be overcome through one Avenue the
grace and mercy of God oh Jesus and the
word of the Lord Romans 3 23 States for
all Ascend and come short of the glory
of God this couple like me have a sin
nature the Bible
[Laughter]
is out loud that this couple who again
who didn't act to get pregnant like me
right he said this couple who said like
me is he saying is he saying that he
would do an act that would get a 12 year
old pregnant or something is that what
he's saying here because I don't know
what he's trying to say and honestly
this looks scripted doesn't it to you
like he's reading this I can't I
couldn't they wrote this [__] down they
broke this [__] down for him they
definitely wrote it down I mean you know
looking looking at his his eyes he
doesn't look too there was like there
was too much movement but uh yeah do not
disparage Samuel Catherine Catherine on
Facebook I want I want to publicly
apologize at this point I really do want
to uh Sam if you're listening I'm very
sorry I did not I promise please please
don't don't take anything I said about
Samuel seriously I was only joking
um this guy definitely is not on the
caliber of Sam Elliott in any way shape
or form other than he's trying to
emulate his mustache so Sam I apologize
publicly for
any defamation or disparagement that I
made look Sam Ellis gonna come he's
going to show up at your door so he's
like hey Tony I uh I heard you were
talking about me on your podcast like
you know how [__] awesome that would
be oh that'd be awesome
dude I would get my [__] camera I'm
like whoa resay that [__] please I'm
gonna boost this online okay so he goes
into the Bible [__] right and the first
stop when he goes to the Bible he's like
oh well
um I'm I'm the same as the 12 year old
boy who did action to get the 12 year
old girl like he's like right
all like the 12 year old boy we've all
impregnated a little girl right like
what the [__] [__] okay let's let's see
if he if he brings Jesus into this
anymore Jesus Christ literally Bible
goes on to say in Romans 6 23 for the
wages of sin is death but the gift of
God Jesus Christ in essence yeah the
payment for our sin is death okay
however Jesus Paid the payment for our
sin because he lived a perfect life
what he's arguing here is he's saying
that because Jesus done right for our
sins right that we if we commit sins
don't have to die which means that if
you rape and impregnate a 12 year old
girl correct you don't have to get you
don't have to die you don't have to go
it's not a sin actually it's already
been forgiven because Jesus knew before
right he's like okay future proof your
rape of this little girl you're good
homie right hey hey wish.com Sam Elliott
everything is cool right everything is
cool the [__] that you're doing and the
[__] you're voting on because you have
these impulses to want to [__]
impregnate our excuse me
do actions that impregnate 12 year old
girls everything's fine because I've
already paid for that sin no problem
like Jesus washed away Jesus on the
cross looks up at at gonna Go's forgive
them Father for they know not what they
do also some of them are going to rape
little girls and I just want you to know
that my death is just going to cover
like tabula rasa we're gonna Blank Slate
just no one has to die if they in fact
do that Mulligan yeah Mulligan on the
whole 12 year old girl thing God's like
the [__] you know
that should be that should be um that
should be a skit I'm just saying here is
here's okay so let's finish it up
because he actually invokes Jesus on the
cross here let's listen cruel death and
resurrected from the dead oh Jesus
Romans 10 9 tells us that if we confess
with our mouth that Jesus is Lord
believe in our heart that God raised him
from the dead
and if we confess if we believe in magic
if we if we believe in magic oh my God
this [__] let me tell you something
Mike moon in that hearing when he tried
to justify what his vote was and the
video went viral the dude should have
just resigned just just [__] resign
go on about your life go be a [__]
lobbyist almost every single one of
these Missouri representatives and
almost every single one of these State
Senators become lobbyists do you want to
do you wanna know why
well because the only person who's going
to give them money is a a soulless
Corporation well well I mean or or some
right-wing [__] trash group but here
here's here's the thing in Missouri in
the 90s
um
we had a referendum on the ballot no I
was too young to vote at the time but
but the referendum on the ballot what do
you mean you're like 78 dude yeah I know
um I was still watching va's VHS tapes
in there but here's the thing in the 90s
there was a referendum on the Missouri
ballot to term limit the United States
excuse me state representatives and
state senators right it was to term them
so they can only serve so many terms now
what happened was is you get a new batch
of idiots every [__] couple years
okay because literally there there is
all kinds of people who have to end up
being State reps and what happens is is
there's a new batch of dumb [__] yeah
every couple years because they don't
know how to legislate they don't know
how to [__] write bills they don't
know how this [__] Works they have no
clue and what ends up happening is the
lobbyists run the state because the
lobbyists know how to write bills the
lobbyists knows how the legislative
process works they pick and choose who
who are the power who hold the power in
the house and the senate in Missouri and
that's because there's term limits so
when someone says the term limit [__]
like oh we should give them terminal
it's like no they have a term limit We
the People the government get to [__]
fire them if we want to because their
term has a limit of what that term is
that's the limit of the term so what
ends up happening in Missouri is you
have some dumb [__] some stupid
racist bigoted [__] pressing
their stupidity on the rest of the state
and it's all [__] It's all under the
[__] vision of these lobbyists and
these special interests right-wing
special interest groups in Missouri and
the only reason why is because these
people don't know what the [__] they're
doing they have no clue when they come
into office they the lobbyists take them
by the by the [__] collar like come
on friend we're gonna give you all kinds
of training on how to be a lobbyist when
you're done being a a I mean look
because you're going to make hundreds of
thousands of dollars being a Lobby
lobbyist because that's what I was the
lobbyist who used to be a representative
is now taking under their wing the
Missouri [__] reps who are brand new
and turning them into lobbyist
eventually that's what they're doing I
mean that's it's grooming right
lobbyists grooming is really what it is
but look at Margaret Taylor green right
she didn't know [__] and Laura Loomer
last week came out in a Twitter space
and was like look uh and also Ali
Alexander was like look none of this
[__] none of the [__] that uh Marge knew
like she didn't know anything when she
came into Congress she was trying to uh
to help platform Laura Loomer and Laura
Loomer was like oh this and Martin
Luther King's like oh I didn't know
about that oh can you help me write some
tweets can you help me with this
legislation all this stuff like points
of view and you have
you have Margaret Taylor green a sitting
congressman who didn't know anything who
was taking her cues from a a self uh
described and proud uh islamophobe right
a Maga Q Anon
um you know first amendment I'm being
suppressed uh type of person was giving
the talking points to Margaret Taylor
green so if you wonder where she got
those talking points or how these people
in in in in in other bodies of
government are getting their their
points of view like it's not from them
it's from other [__] idiots it's from
other corrupt idiots
who either through their own malicious
intent or through their own dumb ass
kind of perspective are influence in
other people to groom them to be just
like them right so it's funny when you
when you see a group of Republicans
you're like ah don't be sheep we're a
bunch of lions we're our own man we're
not we're not com we're not we're not a
bunch of conformists that's the
Democrats and then you're like you guys
all wear the same stuff say the same
stuff uh use your money at the same
place like there's nothing different
about you guys right other than your
first and last name which is probably
[__] Chad Smith all [__] Chad
Smith
well Catherine points out a good point
here she says Jess Piper has been
screaming from the rooftops and most of
these fakers run unopposed and that's
and that's Missouri a lot of people
don't even know there's a race right and
we we have we've had Jess on the show
and maybe maybe this is a good idea
Catherine thank you for bringing this up
maybe we should have Jess on next week
to talk about Mike Moon and talk about
these issues because listen it's not
just Tennessee where this is happening
it's not just Missouri where this is
happening this is happening on state
levels everywhere and now now that the
Tennessee Republicans and the Missouri
Republicans are doing vile gross [__] I
I mean Jesus Christ I got another
[__] video here that we don't have
time to show I think it's Idaho where
the [__] was this guy he was talking
about abortion
um oh [__] I got the video here this
answer there's another [__] in the
state yeah Nebraska excuse me Nebraska
Nebraska
Republicans are more [__] I mean Corn
Huskers right they're moving for for
anti-lgbt bills they're they're moving
on
um bills to take away Women's Health
Care based on the great replacement
Theory I mean it's [__] it's weird
ass [__] well you're you know what [__]
it let me let me see if I can
um get this video going here amazing and
I'll show you this video this is this is
again this is out of Nebraska
um and I believe let's see I think his
name is McDonald uh so let's listen
we have killed 2 000 babies since
abortion became legal oh Jesus
those are 2 000
people in the state of Nebraska I wanna
I wanna clarify something he is actually
misspeaking here he means 200 000 but
he's saying two thousand and the reason
why he's having this 40 inch slip here
with the number is because he doesn't
actually believe this [__] he didn't
actually leave it he's using made-up
[__] numbers and [__] that's made up
about abortions and Women's Health Care
to [__] oppress women in this Alaska
that's why he can't he doesn't know the
difference in the speech between two
hundred thousand two thousand because
he's a [__] liar and he's using
made-up [__] to [__] lies to oppress
his hatred on other people and get in
their [__] business but listen to how
he uses a great replacement here this is
[__] weird wild [__] listen that
could be working and filling some of
those positions and we have vacancies
they're not here
our state population has not grown
except by those foreigners who have
moved here are refugees who've been
priced here
why is that it's because we've killed
200 000 people these are people we've
killed and he is saying literally out
loud hey white baby's dad which is not
the truth white babies died so now we
got brown people here and it's but also
placement but also the this whole
argument about oh well now we can just
throw him into labor for us man like
that's what they want right they they
want they want sanity kids they think
kids and then they think labor like
immediately they're like kids work child
labor and Jess Piper which brings it
around full circle Catherine thank you
Jess Piper the last time she was on the
show she talked about voucher systems
are a slow march to [__] child labor
laws being Stripped Away like Arkansas
did yeah so maybe we should have uh Jess
back on the show I think I think I might
uh send your message after but it really
it really does show you man Republicans
they they do not have any actual
Solutions because what they're what they
want to do
is throw people at a problem right and
there are certain problems in life that
you can't like they're like oh we're
gonna make this better we're gonna make
it uh more efficient whatever like
Republicans are the problem they're the
type of people in the company who are
like oh we've got this problem with the
company we're losing money you know how
we fix it we throw more people on it
which is like the more costly thing that
you would ever do
uh but the fact that he's like oh you
know what we have these babies
and we still even if you want to talk
about how old kids have to be like oh we
have a [__] pre-teen baby right a kid
we need those kids to work hard we need
that we need that boy to go to the
factory and go work there yeah [__] the
labor laws that we put in place to
protect kids from actual dying to make
sure that people were safe but also when
that baby comes home with his little
lunchbox that has like [__] cars logo
on it he's gonna come home to see his
little baby girl wife
in front of the on a stool in front of
the sink washing the dishes and making
sure that dinner's ready because now
they have a new baby that's coming into
town and that baby is going to be the
next Generation that's going to follow
daddy baby into the Factory and then
little little girl baby is then going to
be helping mommy baby inside the house
folding the laundry and cooking the
stuff and putting you know getting stuff
out of the oven washing the dishes
that's the thing that they want they
think the younger they are the younger
they can have babies the better we are
at no I'm checking our our percentage
population of white people right so this
Nebraska state Center's name is Steve
Erdman excuse me I misspoke earlier it's
Erdman e-r-d-m-a-n Erdman here he
definitely wants uneducated white people
to make sure they populate the state in
Nebraska
it's like if I keep his young [__] young
dumb and I won't finish the rest of that
statement
uh that is what the Republican party
wants right that is what they they want
100 they want young people they want
young people who they can force not to
go to school right because they want to
defund education so they want to have
private school or in a rather not
private school they want to have home
school we're able to indoctrinate your
kids with religious beliefs your
anti-government beliefs you're you're
this or that whatever it might be to
then say okay great well the next step
in your life is to go to work and the
kid's like well I'm only lesbian he's
like stop talking back to me kid you're
going to the [__] Factory that's what
they want right they want a kid that's
young that's you know disposable like oh
if the kid dies we'll just make another
one if the kid dies we'll just make
another one wouldn't have to waste 20
years for this kid to raise up go to
school get educated and then go into
work we got half that time they're like
we got a 10 year old kid who's able to
do he's got little hands it's great to
fit in cogs and get things out of right
because that's what they're like oh
little hands yeah those little hands can
pull anything out of there like like
little hands great for plumbing you know
how you know it's it's just like I can't
even believe that this first instinct
when he's talking about children being
born or not born is number one the great
replacement and then we need labor we
need labor it's really dumb they face
plant all the time
make sure that the kid you know grows up
to have a nice healthy loving loving
life right even if you wanted to put the
religious aspect on it you're like oh
look this kid grows up and you know we
wanted to follow the path of God and
Christ and follow those sermons and
those preachings right like okay fine
whatever you want to argue that but then
if you oh somebody asked where the
little hands are yeah so a little bit
little baby she did say hands little
little baby hands these are the hands
that the Republican party wants to use
for labor they want those little hands
fitting inside the tiny spaces that the
big adult hand that's overseen the
factory or whatever the harsh conditions
are wouldn't be able to do right they're
like ah you know what why do we need to
pay for that machine we've got a little
baby here that can crawl in and get it
out for us right that is the Republican
party they don't care if babies die they
don't care if babies are healthy they
just need the babies to be replacing to
well they need the babies to increase
their population size but then also they
need the babies just like oh great we
don't have to risk Our Lives we can just
tell the babies what to do and that is
uh that is exactly I mean like someone
someone I just saw someone say dark
humor it's not dark humor this is the
truth these are people they're saying
this [__] in legislative bodies on the
record you look at other states where
they're like oh well let's repeal this
law that protected against having child
labor like that's the right Governor the
governor of Arkansas is rolling back
child labor laws so that so that
companies and really honestly parents
can take advantage of child labor they
can they can and I think and like I'll
make a joke of it and I'll and I will I
will I will try to bring some humor into
it but the unfortunate reality is it is
true right this is what they're pushing
for they just they want younger kids
they want them dumb uneducated they want
them breeding to make sure that they can
pass through their their indoctrinated
religious white supremacists bigoted
views you know they don't want an
education system they don't want public
education they don't want diverse
education they don't want having an
outside perspective to say oh [__] you
know what America's really [__] up
maybe I shouldn't you know support these
things or maybe I shouldn't live here
maybe I should go broaden my horizons
and go elsewhere right but instead they
want them to stay in the town they want
them to stay with the family they want
them to stay in that job they want them
to stay doing that thing for the rest of
their lives right which which is a very
short-sighted and dumb
dumb mentality but we know the
Republican party doesn't think they
don't think things through they think uh
very short-sighted right they think oh
well if I fix this problem if I fix this
problem right now by having more kids
then it's fixed forever right it's just
like the inflation it's just like gas
prices it's just like trying to expel
Justin Jones and Justin Pearson they do
not think past the act of doing it they
don't think of the repercussions right
just like you look at repealing the EPA
you think at repealing all these these
regulations that were put in place to
protect us right
the Republican party doesn't think about
those things they go oh this is a win we
own the libs we got them I disagree with
you I think they are thinking about it
just like our local librarian here the
My Librarian says if you control
education you control the people okay
that isn't really a good point really
honestly I I think I would take it one
step further and say if you don't
educate people you definitely control
them that was their goal your goal is to
have remember what Donald Trump said oh
I love the poorly educated yeah I love
them of course he does because if you're
not educated then I control you thank
you right mind you librarian I'm gonna
go one more thing before we go to
bonehead because we were going to try to
get it to like
uh two hours today we're not gonna We're
not gonna get two hours we'll do a short
and let's do a short and bonehead we'll
go 30 minutes
yeah you're funny okay I want to point
out a bonehead here before we go to
break the bone end of the week are you
pointing out cat turd and Donald Trump
Jr the interview of the century
literally Donald Trump Jr interviewed
cat turd on his triggered podcast this
is not this is real you did not just no
you did not make this this is you
[__] screenshot this was this was me
watching I watched this interview live
before I was like I can't take this
anymore and I just like wait got a
screenshot because the questions that he
asked were well I think that was like
the second question he asked which was
like so how did you come to be who you
are and I just want to point this out if
anyone on the internet wants to go
search around for who cat turd is
because we know that the one harder to
find anymore well we know who that we
know that one photo was manipulated he's
not really that thumb looking guy
but I will tell you this so in the
interview
cat turd said I live in the south right
he said I joined social media I created
my account four and a half years ago
he said uh he said also when he started
he was 54 which means that right now
he's 58 59 probably
so he and there's other things in the in
the interview where he reveals it but
I'm sure if anyone on the internet
wanted to look around I'm sure you could
find out there's the there's the cat
turd LLC you can find out the location
you can find out who he is you can you
can cross-reference he's got a huge
record is what you're saying yeah I'm
sure she can find really looks it
wouldn't be too hard to find but he was
revealing details about himself and he
was like I'm not going to be he's like
uh he because they talked about being
anonymous and he was like um
he said yeah like I don't I didn't
really plan on this being a thing but
like the left gets so triggered that I'm
Anonymous I don't know anyone who got
triggered that or not we make fun of you
because you're a [__] idiot you you
think that because Nancy Pelosi held the
phone to her ear and it was a dark
screen because that's how a proximity
sensor works you think that there's a
conspiracy that she didn't call the
National Guard or that she wasn't on the
phone with the governor or the mayor or
anyone else
the guy is really the [__] that's inside
the litter box we'll just say he is he
is a cat turd for sure for sure and he's
a bonehead but he didn't make our
bonehead of the week but there are there
are plenty that aren't we're gonna try
to keep it short yeah right
um bonehead of the week right after this
break don't go anywhere bone of the week
next
we'll be right back
Mark 60 seconds this is the Tony
Michaels podcast
[Music]
are you numb and alone after storming
the capital have you been left out in
the cold after stealing Nancy Pelosi's
mail do you feel exposed to a government
that doesn't share your patriotic values
if any of these describe you then you're
in luck hi I'm Paul gosar and thanks to
my new product pardon blanket I've got
you covered part in blanket specifically
Works to make you feel safe and cozy
after your involvement on January 6th
and if you're one of the other members
of Congress who also helped with the
attempted coup hard and blanket will
protect you too hard and blanket is made
of a sort of soft fleece and a layer of
sheep's wool and they're a hundred
percent made in the USA don't delay and
get your pardon blanket today for just
99.99 actual pardon's not guaranteed
jumping back into it this is the Tony
Michaels podcast
welcome back to the show
[Music]
on Friday
we definitely are not gonna go three
hours today yeah I think I think a
little delusion on that but you know
whatever I I'm gonna try I'm gonna drive
bonehead of the week
of the week oh there it goes I don't
know man something's going on with um
somebody somebody said Gabe Wireless
lavalier mic up to your production game
like right now if there's an echo I mean
I'm in a big room that's probably why
yeah that might be it I mean I could
bring it closer you need me to be this
close you want me to be this close I
mean I'm always really close to my back
I mean I can bring it you know I got the
mic right here ASMR type stuff you know
you guys you guys that's what I'm gonna
talk real nice all right all right
you're gonna you're gonna get the you're
gonna get the chat oh excited
the chat's gonna be going wild now over
this okay so
bone of the week let's just get to it
let's play the music bone end of the
week
[Music]
[Applause]
oh I see what they were saying they said
there was an echo they said there was an
echo in the ads that I had oh those are
all films those are filmed from my phone
on a tripod in in my living room that's
why is it the microphone on the phone
yeah I'm just I'm not using anything
like mate I'm like he's not doing
anything special they're just going on
Tick Tock and and Instagram [__] it he
said yes I agree he's up this game since
then yeah that's an old video
okay
oh man okay so our opponents of the week
are you know
two normal ones where the [__] did you
get this picture of this guy what the
[__] they they okay let me just say this
is like a character of him that's our
real picture of him that's a real photo
here I wanna I just want to clarify when
I find these photos I always look for
the worst photos that I can find like
good decent quality image wise but in
terms of uh the faces they make I'm
always like you know looking for a face
where they're like sad or angry or or
you know whatever I think the one of
Donald Trump you guys like yeah yeah uh
but the one when it comes to that that
Jack uh there's just nothing out there
there's there are literally two photos
one is him taking the selfie but the
phone covers his face that's the one
where he's in the military uniform and
there's this one that's the one that was
kind of released yesterday but there's a
second one that was released uh that's
been used which is this one which is him
uh in the academy you only had one
choice for his yeah I had two options
but really one choice right and that's
what it was so he's wearing that the
thing that he's wearing it was also cut
off because where the photo was taken
but he has a little like uh like a
little cap oh it's a cap on so that's
that's why it looks weird but I I
literally could go the furthest up I
could I could do it
um so it looks like he's because it
looks like his hair is painted it looks
like he's got like a like a Widow's Peak
like a major widow's peak you know like
Whoa man look at that two-headed monster
like yeah yeah yeah yeah like like Ted
Cruz's love child or something or you
might say like uh you know like um
who else would it be
um Eddie Munster no Eddie Munster I know
but who's the adult version now
no no uh wow why can't I think of his
name
oh my God Republican Wisconsin speaker
of the house oh you're talking about
Paul Ryan there we go I was like I know
it's called why am I thinking why am I
thinking I was like do you think this
might be this might be
um Paul Ryan's love child is it could be
it could be I don't know they might find
that they align and I I don't know
apologies maybe he's from Massachusetts
so it's a ways away from Wisconsin but
he's real he's still white racist right
well we have another
we have another white racism on the um
the bone of the week we have Tucker
Carlson
um
Clarence Thomas now well I mean that too
he loves I mean I mean Clarence Thomas
is a white racist if you ask me I mean
he's he's he's a he's a Clayton Bixby
character is what he is right right if
no one knows who Clayton Bixby is uh the
Dave Chappelle Show yeah first episode
first the pilot episode I'm gonna
release this sketch he's a black guy who
is a white supremacist and he's blind
and so he says no he says white power
because he doesn't know he's well until
the very end of the the clip which is
the um Crescendo and the joke at the
very end is the best but anyways let's
get back to the business at hand here
let's let's figure out why Decker
Carlson what's the reason why Decker
Carlson is this this um speaking of
racism this is Justin Pearson uh yeah do
you want me to play is that the one yeah
yeah is that the thing is that the
reason why we put him on Bona of the
week or yeah the other reason that well
it was kind of it was kind of twofold
right so before his show last night that
we yeah yeah so he went up as uh as a
racist right because that's what he is
but then he stayed up uh because of his
his um
his recent comments that were made about
the the Jack traitor kid oh okay so
let's tie it into that let's do that
here's a clip here's a clip that acen
has yeah on which didn't age well
there's gonna be I'm gonna do a what was
that on Tucker Carlson because there's a
clip from a little few years ago where
he says the complete opposite okay well
let's listen to this clip this is from
last night Im talking about Jack Trader
the the young Discord dude who the
racist the the ammo sexual racist Jack I
mean look at the Chiron they they will
tell you the Guardsman is the criminal I
mean did he not steal classified
documents and then disseminate them on
the internet right well and this isn't
okay so a lot of people have been
comparing
um this leak of documents to Trump
stealing documents and they've been
camering comparing it to reality winner
there's
a array of differences between all three
of these things number one Donald Trump
didn't put the documents that he stole
that we know of on a Discord okay yeah
stole them from us we don't know the
motivation yet I'm sure Jack Smith's
going to get to the bottom of that
um but we don't know the motivation yet
but it doesn't appear that Donald Trump
put them on a Discord maybe a thumb
drive and a laptop but not Discord and
reality winner didn't steal these to own
some other [__] cuck online yeah
Discord where they were playing war
games okay reality winner
disclose classified information to let
America know that yes Russia was trying
to [__] with our voting machines yeah so
there's there's array of differences
between these three cases and how they
would be handled in the Department of
Justice that's why they swiftly arrested
reality winner when she did what she did
because it was traced back to her almost
immediately and the same way with this
dumb [__] who put who put these things
on Discord to apparently own his is that
am I getting that right he put it on he
did put it on Discord so he yeah so he's
got a Discord and uh he put it on there
because there was you know some argument
in terms of who was right and he's like
[__] and he's like and so he went and
got the information he put it up
classified information
right oh here's I owned you yeah okay
really got owned there because it's
what's interesting about it is the fact
of like how long it took it was also on
because there's a there's a they traced
it back to where the Discord what like
where the origin point was and they're
like it's it stayed on another Discord
for like 10 days and no one really did
anything about it and then it was and
then they traced it back to another and
then they traced it eventually back to
his original Discord but they're like it
was on another Discord which didn't
which wasn't very political but some
things were brought up and it stayed on
the Discord and there was like very
little activity if I remember correctly
what I read
um
and it wasn't until like the final
Discord did it like blow up but again
this is an alpha cuck yeah he wanted to
try to prove something online because
he's a [__] he's a goddamn white
racist in cell probably so he had a lot
to prove so he broke a lot of federal
laws that's gonna give him in a lot of
trouble and put him in a federal prison
for a long time just to own someone on a
game chat or whatever the hell it is but
here's Tucker Carlson trying to defend
that piece of [__]
um and again you can see the Chiron but
let's listen to his words that's I think
more important now our news media exists
and have constitutional protection
precisely in order to push back against
this grotesque standard their only job
is to tell the truth and yet tonight the
news media are celebrating the capture
of the kid who told Americans what's
actually happening in Ukraine they are
treating him like Osama Bin Laden maybe
a little worse actually because unlike
Al Qaeda apparently this kid is a racist
oh oh see so now it comes down to Tucker
Carlson is mad because this guy was
arrested because he's white this goes
into the whole stupid thing of fragile
fragile white male existence that they
want to be oppressed in this country
shut the [__] up man this kid this
stupid [__] thought he'd owned
someone online by posting highly
classified documents online on a Discord
by taking pictures of them who gives a
[__] about what is true and what is not
the [__] putting National
Security in and our our people in
Ukraine's people at risk when people are
gonna get could get killed because his
dumb son of a [__] thinks it is his
right and privilege to steal this in
information to own someone on the
internet [__] you Tucker Carlson you can
go straight to [__] hell you piece of
garbage and when he says when he says
it's the media's [__] responsibility
to tell the truth and the only reason
why they're doing is because they're
scared of Ukraine Russia we've talked
about this on Tuesday with Texas Paul
the more you looked at these documents
and the information he's diagnosed the
worse it was for Russia not good for
Russia but also there are two there were
two versions right there was one version
that went out which was the original and
there was a second version that went out
that was manipulated to think to show
the opposite which was Russia was good
there were less deaths that were
actually happening and Ukraine was the
one that was actually losing but we know
why Tucker Carlson and Margaret Taylor
green and these other Republicans are
very Pro whistleblower now which is
crazy to think about that they're Pro
whistleblower now before they're like
[__] The Whistleblower go to jail this
person be sentenced to death all this
[__] right then you have this guy a
white racist uh straight man
religious probably uh
uh guy who was doing his patriotic Duty
by revealing the inside scoop of what
was going on with you know uh with
Ukraine versus Russia but we have to
remember that these people Marge Taylor
green Tucker Carlson all these other
people are [__] Putin simps they're
pro-russia anti-ukraine and if there's
anything that they can do to own the
libs own the ukrainians be Pro uh broke
I would say prohaler but yeah pro-hiller
but also Pro Putin they're gonna do I
mean they're gonna do it right
and the other thing too is like
they're gonna they wanna argue that this
guy's a whistleblower but he's not a
whistleblower he didn't no he didn't he
didn't do this because reality winner
when she released that document and I I
would actually love to have her on
um and I don't know if she can or would
talk about this issue but when she did
what she did she was trying to tell the
American people something this kid was
not trying to tell the American people
anything he posted on a Discord to own
another [__] anonymous online user on
Discord get the [__] out of here with
this nonsense but let's see how Tucker
Carlson reacted to reality winner in
2017. let's see what his reaction I'm
sure it's the exact same as it was
same energy same energy let's see let's
see dysfunction and all over allegations
that Vladimir Putin somehow hacked our
democracy on behalf of Donald Trump yet
after all this time the only actual
crime that have surfaced during the
course of this Scandal appeared to have
been committed not by the president but
by his opponents who have leaked reams
of classified material in order to hurt
him that's a felony by the way and it's
happened a lot some weeks almost every
day the latest example comes from the
National Security Agency the NSA a 25
year old contractor with the name
reality winner supposedly her real name
is accused of leaking classified
surveillance of Russian hackers now the
document suggests an effort to penetrate
U.S election software though not to
change vote totals not that Details
Matter in this case the whole thing just
sounds Sinister and that of course was
the point of the leak to add the
perception that Trump is somehow a
foreign agent okay so he doesn't have
the same stance on the leaker but do you
see the through line of who he's
supporting here on the bull stories who
he's actually in support of do you see
who he who why Tucker Carlson is
broadcasting every night to hold up a
[__] murderous dictator do you see
the through line there I mean it's
always like in both stories in the way
of Putin's the victim here yeah well I
mean I mean I mean he says Trump in the
end but really in the beginning he's
like Putin it was to blame Vladimir
Putin for rigging the election I mean
isn't that what the v in in his name
stands for victim Putin I guess so I I
thought his name was victim Putin and
not Vladimir Putin Tucker Carlson you
pile a [__] [__] you [__] Putin
puppet pile of [__] [__] you you
[__] you I mean he is I mean
let's just Dr Carlson is a uh Russian
asset he definitely is uh he is well if
he's not God damn I I can't believe he's
doing it for free right I mean even even
during his interview with Donald Trump
as sad as empathetic as that interview
was
any time they talk about Putin they're
like oh well Putin believes that
Ukraine's his and he would never do
these things if I was President Bud's
actually a very smart guy very very you
know and then he's like oh yeah also Kim
Jong-un very smart very very intelligent
it's like why are you why in the [__]
are you [__] saying such nice things
about these dictators I mean rhetorical
question I know why
but the fact that you're doing on TV to
be like Putin not a bad guy totally
respects me and I respect him yeah he
killed some people but like whatever wow
right it would be the same people I
would kill I mean really he's like Kim
Jong-un the end of the day yeah I mean
the idea that he's just doing he's like
oh yeah you know Kim Jong-un not a bad
guy totally nice we played uh [__]
fortnite together he's real cool you
know like it's it he he's he's talking
about these people as if
as if he was [__] Harlan Hitler right
like and he had his own little uh
dictator statues in a garden somewhere
that's Donald Trump I mean we do know
that Donald Trump did have Minecraft on
his bedside table right is that true I
don't know if it was a signed copy or
not no I don't know if it was signed I
don't know but it definitely was like
well I mean you know real billionaires
can afford signed copies yeah that is
very big ones real billionaires can oh
we're gonna dictator we're gonna talk
about Harlan Hitler here in a minute
yeah but but first I want to go to uh
Jack Trader here Margaret Taylor Green's
best new friend
um in the world because he is a shooter
like what I don't know but I'm sure
she's dying to
um now I don't have a lot of video to
show you on this Jack guy because it
doesn't exist because he is a nobody he
was a nobody on Discord and that's what
he was trying to prove that he isn't a
nobody on Discord that's exactly what he
was doing is trying to prove I'm not a
nobody look at me I've got information
that you don't have and you can't see
which is what got him in [__] trouble
but what I will say since we just played
the Tucker Carlson video on Fox News I
want to play another [__] Alpha cook
on
um foxy he's not our Apple cook of the
day but I definitely want to play
another Alpha tuck on Fox News his take
on this whole thing when this blew up in
their face because they were really
hoping the Biden Administration did this
right yeah and they were really hoping
someone in the Biden Administration did
this which it was not it would clearly
is just some [__] cuck that got his
feelings hurt online and is trying to
prove something to someone else who is
probably a [__] cuck online but just
Jesse Waters here the the other Fox News
cuck talks about the online cut getting
arrested now this video shows two
different things you're gonna see
um the the internet cuck the internet
Trader here who leaked the documents
you're going to see him being arrested
by the feds he's right here by the truck
and he actually walked backwards the
reason why they arrested him like this
as opposed to the reason why they
arrested reality winner the way they
arrest her is because he had a lot of
videos online
um as an ammo sexual 2A bro like
shooting [__] and homosexual that's a
good that's a good friend [__] yeah
well I I stole it but he was he was you
know shooting at targets yelling racial
epithets anti-semitic epithets so they
thought maybe this guy was probably
dangerous right I mean which maybe maybe
not now there is a video out there and I
don't know if I'll be able to pull it up
of him on his back porch reading a book
on his back porch before they come to
his house and again I'm just I'm just
making assumptions here I don't have any
evidence but I would imagine that
there's a very good chance that it was a
mind comp copy
um maybe even one that Harlan Hitler
sent him you know he's really possible
he likes Traders so you know I don't
know Harlingen or probably her
existrator but let's listen now Jesse
Waters this is the dumbest [__] I have
ever seen so this is how he's framing up
almost immediately after this guy's
arrested listen to this this is
oh my God Jesse you are such a dumb [__]
this is gonna face plant on Jesse Waters
let's listen
I don't trust anything about this story
oh Jesus I'm with Greg
this is more than the fog of War I
assume the government's lying to me I
assume the media is lying to me so when
they say you are the media
in Massachusetts that leaked this thing
I don't know I don't know he's not a
gamer he's a Guardsman I don't know if
they're half real half true
disinformation yeah that's the whole
point that's what we're trying to tell
you dumb [__] I'm allowed to
read
I think you can read them but if you
actually if you this is kind of weird if
you have a classified security clearance
you are not allowed to read them okay no
it's not it's not that you're not
allowed to read them when you have a
classified uh when when you actually
have access decoding Fox and you said
this by the way yeah when you when you
have clearance to look at these
documents it's part of your oath and
it's part of your clearance that you
cannot release these documents whether
it be the documents themselves are
verbally into the public so someone who
has a clearance who wants to keep it
would not be able to read them out loud
or show them to people because they have
to respect classified information that's
the reason why they arrested this dumb
[__] Jesse oh my God so um you
know
that's the other bonehead I'm actually
surprised that this Jack character
didn't win but I think it's because no
one really knows who he is right yeah
he's a nobody he's still a no even with
all of this media attention he's still a
nobody well he's gonna remain to nobody
for the rest of his life for a long time
yeah I mean people are not going to talk
about uh are gonna people are not going
to be talking about him just like the
[__] dumbass conservative Ultra right
beer No One's Gonna Be talking about
that [__] and people are going to forget
about who this person is they're gonna
be like Jack who like Jack what like No
One's Gonna remember who this guy is
unless he's brought up and then
sometimes he's like wait who are you
talking about they're like oh well he's
no bad guy and then you have to explain
it and you're like well okay so that's
what he did he he stole classified
documents oh they're gonna say oh he was
the manga Trump supporter who is a
traitor right um which is kind of
funny you know yeah and be like oh he's
a whistleblower what was he blowing the
whistle about like what was what did he
reveal he exposed secrets about an
ongoing war between a dictator and a
bunch of people trying to defend
themselves you know who are the underdog
right that's really what you show it
only shows that this guy was trying to
help support Putin because that's how
right-wing media and that's and that was
his thought process too yeah that Putin
was winning and here's the proof
um here is uh because we gotta go to the
dishonorable mention which it falls
right in line with a traitor um because
she is a traitor representative Margaret
Taylor green and not only is she a
traitor she says it out loud on her
Twitter account her official
Congressional Twitter account at that
it's [__] insane that she would even
[__] post this
but this is the timeline and the stupid
[__] we have to deal with in today's
world when you have people like this
stupid ass [__] yes I use the word
because it is appropriate to use the
word with this [__] yeah it might that
might my fans in Australia like that
word like when we use that word it
doesn't offend them in Australia
I've got uh comedian friends who I've
performed with from Australia and
they're like I was like oh yeah it [__]
a different way it's yeah it's not the
same thing
how how is that again how was that again
uh
uh what how's what the hell your
Australian friends tell you oh that's
like I I can't yeah it's not the same
thing a [__] [__] yeah
yeah what is what does [__] mean in
Australia it's just like
um
like uh how did they describe it it's
like [__] right it's like it's like
it doesn't mean it doesn't mean the same
way that's the way I'm saying yeah
it's like barely you know or whatever
but it's like it's it's used in like an
endearing kind of way like I wouldn't be
like oh you know out here like oh you
call someone a [__] you're like oh whoa
what the [__] right all right people get
people get really [__] they get their
guard up when you bring out the car yeah
now when I say it to when I say it about
like Marjorie Taylor green or Marshall
Blackburn or bobert
um they don't people people are like
look I don't like the word gun and
they'll probably put it in the comments
as I'm saying this now like I don't like
the word [__] but if you're gonna use it
describe them I'm okay with it
with that right there's a caveat here
there's a scene from Curb Your
Enthusiasm where they have the crew back
from Seinfeld and they're at a party and
they're talking about
um
uh Jason Alexander's book where it's
like I think it was a book about acting
or something it was like a very thin
book whatever he's like oh they're like
talking about something he's like yeah
but
with that being said you know and it's
it just goes it's like when somebody
says something and there's like a huge
butt in the claws we're like yeah that's
nice but hey it's kind of this you know
see you next Tuesday honestly it is
right it is it is funny when someone is
like you see you next week and you're
like see you next Tuesday yeah and they
don't know what you're talking about
they're like all right see ya okay so um
the the representative [__] here
I I don't even know if I'm white I don't
even know if I want I don't even know if
I want to [__] read this out loud
that's how treasonous this [__] is you
do okay you can let everyone else read
the rest of it but I would say the first
line is everything you need to know well
and and the reason why is because this
is what she loves about him right like
this is the thing you wouldn't say the
same thing if he was uh not white right
or or if he was trying a trans man yeah
or or or an atheist yeah or or for you
crane having their sovereignty and not
being invaded by by the murderous
dictator of Vladimir Putin it really
says more about Marjorie Taylor green
than it does about uh Jake texria or
whatever the hell however the hell you
say his name I don't know Parisi had
terexia I don't know
um traitor Jake Trader is white male
Christian and anti-war and she goes on
to say that makes him an enemy of the
Biden regime which
I don't know why she doesn't know this
but the Biden regime had nothing to do
with this [__] releasing this on
Discord or trying to track him down and
[__] Prosecuting him just like just
like when reality winner did it she was
prosecuted under the doj of the Trump
administration because she broke federal
laws listen
um I I
believe that reality winner had a
completely different motivation of
releasing the documents that she
released but she did break federal law
she did she intended she knew she was
breaking federal law how many years did
it for one document right but the but
the point but the point here is that
this idea that somehow Biden is the one
doing this to Jake Trader because he's
white male Christian and and for Putin
makes no sense whatsoever I mean you're
you're now simping Marjorie Taylor green
for a [__] white supremacist who is
an ammosexual who shoots targets while
he's yelling screaming racial and
anti-semitic epithets who is pro-putin
who who in a cuck move steals classified
documents of our government that that
violates our homeland security that you
are a [__] Committee Member on that
committee you [__] [__]
and he broke a sovereign oath as a
[__] Guardsman to release these to
own some other [__] on a Discord server
you [__] stupid [__]
ah anyways how does that feel that feels
great to yell and scream at at this
traitor it's Marjorie green it is
amazing to see uh you know after after
this was released because there you know
I was watching reports and it was like
you know the the flight pattern of
helicopters and they've they saw the
footage of them going in
and you would assume that every
Republican be like yeah man those are
National Secrets like you don't want to
have uh you don't want to have that
release but then you're like oh well
they did kind of support Trump and but
they did try to claim that it was under
his the presidential you know records
act so I guess maybe they would defend
this but still he's not that important
and he's still some pretty classified
documents that were released and uh
doesn't help
you would think that
you would you would see Republicans say
hey I mean okay I will say this
George Santos of all people said he was
uh before
here I'll actually pull up the tweet and
I'll show you because it is a it is a
well that with that being said because
he has a moment in his tweet where he's
for the punishment of this Jack traitor
and then in response he then says well
also buying watch
so is it like I'm not racist butt type
thing yeah it's kind of it's a what
aboutism it's like when they when they
talk to George Santos and they're like
so you lied about this stuff it was oh
yeah sure I lied but Joe Biden's been
lying for July really what's a lie
really what's a lie I mean yeah I killed
some dogs and I I didn't go to school I
never had two knee Replacements I never
worked on Wall Street I may or may not
have uh stolen money from several people
in New York as well as an elderly man
that my mother was working for in Brazil
and no it's uh not a real story but yes
I am admitting fault in there and it's
like
anyway so here's here's your buddy
George Santos yeah I'm gonna let you
read it since you've actually talked to
him in real life going yeah yeah so Jack
Trader's actions irreparably compromise
National Security and he must be held
accountable all right I agree with that
uh and with that being said Biden has
lied to the American people for 40 plus
years cost enough us lives and taxpayer
dollars Biden has failed to protect
American interests here or abroad
without accountability
I mean literally literally if you're
gonna believe me
if you're guys if you're gonna blame
this guy's arrest on biting he's
actually protecting National Security
you [__] idiot I mean this is the
same group of people these Republicans
say oh Biden should be more pro-law and
Order and pro cops and okay fine like
we're we're following the rule of law
we're arresting these people we're doing
this and then as soon as those people
get arrested like whoa they're not knows
we don't want you to rest we don't want
you to arrest those we were talking
about the time we meant
[Music]
is Joe sleeping in a basement somewhere
on a on a lazy recliner or is he you
know being the Puppeteer that's pulling
the strings on all these things
internationally and domestic I don't
know how are you supposed to tell
speaking though of fragile white males
yep did you know there's a pudding
finger civil war going on yeah I heard
about that and and and one fragile white
male
is being cucked this morning uh his name
is Ron DeSantis there's a lot of Rhonda
Santos news um but the alpha cooking
that happened this morning
by by Donald Trump to Governor Ron
DeSantis is beautiful this is I mean it
is magnificent we couldn't have produced
the commercial any better Liz really
honestly I know you're listening and I
know you're you're taking notes this
commercial I don't know what we said in
that episode where you were listening
about you should produce the pudding
finger commercial but you were spot on
baby because I'll tell you something
when when it comes down to it rather
Ron's the nominee or Trump's the nominee
we definitely are going to use this
commercial in the general election
against you stupid [__] it is
gonna be beautiful watch this this is
from the Trump pack make America great
again Incorporated on Ron DeSantis
eating pudding with his [__] three
fingers watch this Ron DeSantis loves
sticking his fingers where they don't
belong and we're not just talking about
pudding DeSantis has his Dirty Fingers
all over senior entitlements what
hunting Medicare slashing social
security
even raising our retirement age
tell Ron DeSantis to keep his pudding
fingers off our money oh and somebody
get this man a spoon make America great
again ink is responsible for the content
of this advertisement okay first okay
yeah yeah so you go you go well I was
gonna say this guy is really young here
yes really young and thin okay right
right this is not not just fullness but
this is not Rhonda you actually know who
this looks like this guy looks like
everything no no no Josh Hawley oh
I was getting Pete Davidson Vines from
him look at him yeah and I figured I
figured Pete Davidson probably is the
king of the three finger thing I'm just
saying I'm just I'm just saying man just
saying everyone loves Pete Davidson and
it seems like
people that would want Pete Davidson's
three I'm just saying wow I got Pete
Davidson Vibes on this okay
well what I'll say is
Josh Holly you think Josh I honestly
think this is Josh Hawley When I See
This I go oh this looks like
Josh Hawley like it looks like the we
should get a confirmation
I mean I believe it's Josh Hawley and
I'm gonna go forward with the Assumption
it's Josh Hawley I will say I will say I
bet Josh Hawley did do an audition for
this role for sure I I mean look they're
like we're looking for like on the call
sheet they're like we're looking for a
Ron DeSantis type
but we're looking for someone who looks
like Josh Hawley and Joshua look at this
I could be there he's like I'll run
there in a moment like look that you
gotta that looks like
Liz Liz honestly if you're listening
this reenactment it's pretty good you
should really get this kind of
production quality for the for the
Mar-A-Lago videos you should really get
this kind of quality I'm surprised
nobody's uploaded this to Pornhub
um but I I honestly think this is Josh
Hawley I there's you cannot you cannot
convince me otherwise this is Jesus
Christ this is Josh Hawley it's Friday
we're getting nasty here yeah
right you know what the best part about
this is okay so here's the thing it's a
great ad it's a great oh it's great ad
it's a great it's going to be a great ad
in general election here's why
the reason why is because if Rhonda
santis wins we're gonna use this against
him yeah if Donald Trump wins we're
gonna use this against him because
everything Donald Trump's pack accuses
Ron DeSantis in here is everything
Republicans are trying to do everywhere
in the country like take your [__]
entitlements away take your [__]
Liberty away from me take take what your
owed from your tax dollars they're
literally trying to watch watch here we
go DeSantis backing deep cuts to Social
Security Medicare Republican idea yeah
that's a republican also also also also
it should be known that uh
someone said it's Stephen Miller no this
is Steve no no Steve Miller's I think
it's much he's much more ghostly I mean
Steven Miller is barely alive so he's
like and I mean how can you how can you
mistake all the swastikas that he's
tattooed on his body right
um but this this ad right here when you
see him bring up deep cuts to Social
Security and Medicare uh it's very easy
to look back at the cuts that Donald
Trump approved right and pushed through
while he like I think it was two or
three times he made budget cuts to those
very things that's right dude the other
thing too is that you can go back to the
tape of who will be Donald Trump's
opponent yeah out of the State of the
Union Address saying so I'm not gonna
cut Social Security that's not something
we're gonna do I'm gonna veto it and you
agree that I'll be to it so you won't do
it right like literally they're walking
into this and they don't even see it man
this is an ad for Democrats listen folks
if Democrats are going to produce an ad
against Trump or against DeSantis either
way this would be the ad that they would
be running okay so here's the next one
DeSantis voted to cut Social Security
three times do you know where he voted
to cut it three times
do you know where and when Gabe Sanchez
2015 2014 2013 but what was he when he
was voting for these things
no he wasn't Governor he was a state
representative how the [__] how the [__]
is Rhonda Santos going to cut Social
Security when he's this is lies okay so
here we go here it is Rhonda Santos
Razor's retirement age to to 70. do you
know who else is trying to raise
retirement age in this country do you
know which party
I don't know does it start with an R it
starts with a [__] R and it ends with
Nazi
yeah those are one of the same network
you're saying it starts with iron and
ends with Nazi okay the other Ron
DeSantis news and I gotta play this uh
clip of him because this is [__]
wild [__] um Rhonda santis there's a
flood in Fort Lauderdale no one's heard
that
um so Fort Lauderdale is being flooded
and
um and I'm not saying the flood is Ron
DeSantis fault because
this is something that Rhonda Santos can
do he can help the response um he's
tried this stuff before uh where he wore
the white boots here is
um let me see if I can that's not the
there's the one I want okay Grant Stern
has it here uh Christopher Anderson
posted this video this is and this is I
think Christopher the guy who posts this
is in support of Miranda Santos look how
many folks showed up at Ron desantis's
there's like little Summit here in Ohio
for there's like 12. there's like maybe
tens of white people yeah to maybe clap
for Ron DeSantis and I'm I'm not
exaggerating I mean I this is you see
what it is Summit Summit County welcomes
special guest Governor Ronda Santos
weird why would he go to Iowa I don't uh
no not Iowa Ohio
well I mean he is trying to figure out
if his woke message uh sells in these um
uh swing States but let's let's is this
gonna be is this gonna be like a Jeb
Bush moment well watch
political ideology on the students
[Applause]
funded your tax dollars they can't just
do whatever they want they're not play
things of the political left they need
to serve a public purpose and serve
State interest and that's exactly what
we're orienting our education system to
do me in Florida believe in the rights
of parents to direct the education and
upbringing of their children okay so we
could keep going but it's the same old
dribble it's the same old nonsense same
old [__] same old lies they're not
for parents rights they're for taking
consent away from parents and giving it
to the state it's big government fascism
in the State of Florida and he's going
and bragging about it in Ohio to see if
he can sell big government fascism in
Ohio my guess is it's not going to sell
well with Ohioans other than the few
tens of white people that showed up to
his event to clap for the Floridian
fascists which probably half those
[__] people he brought on a plane
with him so I'm just saying I mean
Rhonda in some ways he continues with
his pattern of trafficking humans you
know right well that that is true also
also also yes yeah I'll let you say that
but also I just want to point out again
no one ever took away your rights as a
parent no one ever did that well they're
trying to they're trying they're trying
to by saying this is a bill for parental
rights but what no one ever you could do
whatever you want with your kids you can
take them out of school you can put them
in a different one you can homeschool
them you can do whatever no one is is
taking away the rights of you as a
parent right you get a syllabus you get
a [__] thing at the beginning of the
school year you know exactly what's
going to be taught the kid brings her
backpack home you know if anything just
got parents teacher conference but the
same people normally they'll allow you
to contact your your students teacher if
you need help or if they need help like
it's just it's just one of you involved
like be involved in right and the same
and I'm gonna say right now but the
people who complain about how their
rights are being taken away as parents
are the same people who could not and
cannot be bothered to respond to a
[__] email from the teacher saying
hey your son Joe is doing great or your
son Joe is kind of acting out and we see
some issues and want to have a little
confidence difference with you if you
want to come in
and then boom leave them on red don't
respond don't show up so then it becomes
this one-sided battle where the teacher
has to play both parent and teacher to
the sense of like hey how are things
going you know like I can't talk about
this stuff with you nor should I but uh
where the [__] are your parents you know
well I have to say it one last time for
the alpha [__] of the week [__] around
the scientists oh yeah
[__] him [__] him [__] him
um so let's let's move on to the winner
of this week's bone end of the week
Clarence Thomas so
um do you know why Clarence there's a
lot of reasons why Clarence Thomas could
be on the list but do you what was the
reason why he made this list and well I
mean took off he won this hands down
yeah he really took I mean like Clarence
Thomas joining his white brethren in
this bonehead of the week here uh what
happened what what he's white I'm I'm
saying Ron I'm saying I'm just white
he's a white guy he is a white guy
married to a white woman and a racist a
relationship and he hangs out with
racist people like Hitler uh or Harlan
Hitler Harlan Hitler
um
that's that's one of the stories that
that caused him to be on bonehead of the
week right so what what was it because
we know last week Harlan Hitler was the
guy who has the signed copy of mine cap
he's got pictures of all these
authoritarians he's got a garden that he
has him and he he loves these things
yeah
but it was also revealed that he was
giving luxury gifts to Clarence Thomas
yeah yeah so he was you know he was his
sugar daddy what's the new thing what's
the new thing so the new thing it turns
out because again like I said this
yesterday on on Twitter I was like if
anyone thought that Pro public was just
gonna drop one [__] piece on Clarence
Thomas you you were kidding yeah what no
one had done it wasn't a one and done I
wouldn't be surprised if there were
going to be other boxes new news this
morning because I know you're going to
talk about the house right right so
there's the house so there's the house
that uh that uh Harlan Hitler bought
from or for Clarence Thomas that has
that Clarence Thomas's wife or uh uh
mother lives at correct is it a mother
so that's the news this morning yeah so
that
Harlan Hitler purchased gave gave
Clarence Thomas money for his childhood
home gave him money now they say it's
because he's going to make a museum out
of it yeah but man I thought Clarence
Thomas was just a friend that travels
around on vacation for yeah he just
happens to be there on the luxury Yachts
or
his you travel with some of your friends
right yeah yeah you do extensive travel
you travel so many friends have you ever
thought you know what I'm gonna do since
this friend travels with me all the time
I really want to buy their childhood
home does that ever yeah I've I've
definitely consider that multiple
occasions I thought to myself I thought
to myself hey it would be great to go
back to Chicago and and buy my friend's
home right and give it to him right
because later down here's here's the
news Clarence Thomas's mom
who lived in this home when Harlan
Hitler bought it from Clarence Thomas to
give him money that's what happened
right right he was giving him money but
he had to have a reason to give him this
is called uh laundering money so to get
political influence yeah well Harlan hit
her pays Clarence Thomas for this house
not only does he pay clearance Thomas's
house Clarence Thomas's mother still to
this day
lives at this house so she has been
benefiting from Harlan Hitler's gift not
only has Clarence Thomas his wife
Jeannie benefited from these
non-disclosed gifts
also Clarence Thomas's mother has
[__] benefited from these
non-disclosed gifts so it's a family
affair over there at the Thomas House
well or the Harlan Hitler it's the
Harlan Hitler house I mean
looks it okay right he's like this is my
guest home where I let all my other
racist Nazi uh comrades hang out at
um oh my God it's it's crazy and again
like there's gonna be more because I
wouldn't be if I were reporting on the
story right like you probably have these
stories lined up and you're fact
checking the last remaining details of
them but you're like great we've got the
first the second the third story ready
to go right
um you know like all comedy we run in
rules of three right the rule of three
if you're gonna have the first two set
up there's a third joke coming and I
wouldn't be surprised if there's a third
bombshell that's going to come out of
this uh there could be more after that
but there's a feeling that I feel like
there's gonna be three out of this one
like oh yeah he had these gifts oh yeah
he bought this house and then I feel
like there's a [__] there's a third
one that's like boom that's the dead
ringer right there
and also reveals to anyone who ever had
any doubt about Clarence Thomas and his
political influence that he has by uh by
hanging out with you know or or any any
judge through the federal Society right
you know if they ever had any doubt I'm
I'm hoping that when they see this stuff
right especially whatever this next one
will be because I'm assuming propublica
will have a third one that comes out
that's gonna be like oh yeah he directly
just gave him money like there's gonna
be something where somebody slipped up
and is like oh yeah there was an
exchange of money went to the bank
account for no reason right it wasn't a
purchase it wasn't it wasn't a it wasn't
a stipend to go on a trip or a vacation
or something like that it was just
straight up money that was put into an
account well and this goes to the heart
of what I think is going to be the
question
because it's no longer about luxury
gifts that's given to a friend because
he was going on the same vacation as me
and he's a friend so I'm staying at this
Resort so he would have to stay there
too right like that's this whole [__]
[__] story about how I'm I'm not
giving him gifts he's just my friend
traveling with me I'm just buying his
friendship what's wrong about that but
here here is it's a hundred and thirty
three thousand dollars that Harlan Crow
bought
a house from Clarence Thomas and his
mother lives there he didn't buy him
from his mother apparently he bought it
from Clarence Thomas so it was in
Clarence Thomas's name his mother lives
there now is this unethical absolutely
on its [__] just a bear story but the
question is gonna be is it criminal yeah
and folks I don't know if you noticed
but we're really asking the question in
this country can we criminally prosecute
really powerful people and Republicans
are like oh my God that's the worst
thing in the world I wonder why they're
doing that yeah I wonder why Clarence
Thomas is the one vote the one vote that
made sure that Donald Trump's records
would not be seen by the American public
I wonder why I wonder why Clarence
Thomas is probably terrified that Donald
Trump is [__] indicted on 34 felonies
in the state of New York he's probably
going to be indicting them felonies in
Fulton County Georgia and no telling how
many [__] felons these Jack Smith's
gonna bury this son of a [__] under
I wonder why today
that Clarence Thomas and Jeannie Thomas
might just be [__] their drawers
about how the two-tier justice system
that protects the rich and Powerful in
this country is starting to crash down
because the two-tier justice system that
the Republicans are talking about it is
a two-tier justice system and the reason
why they're terrified of it and they're
yelling and screaming about it is
because their tear is no longer going to
protect them so my question is the
question really about this Clarence
Thomas and he being the [__] bonehead
of the week is is he the criminal of the
week or is he just the bonehead of the
week that's the question that's the
question now we know we know what the
answer was on our Poll for bonehead yeah
yeah we know yeah it was it was
resounding but yeah he's a [__]
bonehead even more than the traitor and
the white supremacist duck or Carl's and
it was crazy so let's give Clarence
Thomas his do
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
Hitler and Donald Trump alike and your
wife for that matter I don't know your
mother but man she's living rent free
and Harlan Hitler's house that she
bought from you yeah like is the plan
that they were gonna wait until she died
and then convert the house into a museum
kind of thing it's weird man it's
[__] this is all [__] crazy ass
[__] and the more that we know the more
that we're not surprised right I'm not
surprised that this happened I'm not
surprised that Clarence Thomas is a
boner of the week I'm telling you
there's gonna be there's gonna be I I
have a feeling there's gonna be another
bombshell I think it's gonna be today
since it's Friday
no I don't know if they drop it on a
Friday because last last time they
dropped on a Thursday too right right
well I don't know but it's getting more
and more closer to Crime right is it
ethics there's a there's a part of me
because there's there's certain things
that you do uh when you're released like
hey I'm releasing an app or a product or
make an announcement or something there
are two days in the week that you want
to do it Tuesday and Thursday because
what happens is you wait for everyone to
get back into the week Tuesday you drop
this announcement to say hey I'm
releasing this product right or I'm
doing a fundraiser whatever it might be
Thursday you want to catch everyone
before the weekend because the weekend's
always gonna be crazy people got [__] to
do they got emails to respond to they're
going on vacation they got this and that
they got all these other obligations
so people typically release stuff on a
Tuesday and Thursday
and I feel if I remember correctly the
last time the the first time that Pro
public had dropped this it was on a
Thursday
and then everyone found out you know
what was happening Friday uh and then
talked about through the weekend
um I wouldn't be surprised if they
waited a few days into the week next
week or whatever it might be the
following week I don't know how like how
many pieces they have and how many
they're lined up but I have a feeling
that there's another piece coming and
they're going to drop it and it's going
to be something that's like very
explicitly like look he took money and
he did this thing or yeah
I have some breaking news on it oh wow
citizens for ethics the crew
um breaking we just filed a civil and
criminal complaints against Clarence
Thomas for his uh failure to disclose
gifts from the property in sales to
Harlan crew as we call him here Harlem
Hitler
um nobody is above the law and not even
the Supreme Court justice so
um the crew is pushing for a criminal
complaint um for Clarence Thomas let me
tell you something if you're not aware
of us Prosecuting uh powerful people it
looks like um we're gonna start doing
that in this country and tearing down
that two tears justice system that the
Republicans are terrified that won't
protect him anymore listen this has been
bone don't go anywhere after the song We
got some a few announcements stick
around a few announcements right after
the song
[Music]
[Applause]
you're muted you're muted I don't know
you were muted oh well at my shit's
running it's the first time for
everything Joni shit's running slow here
it's ticket it's tick-tocking slow oh
yeah like through the graphics today I
don't know what's I don't know if it's
uh it's you it's probably it's you every
time speaking speaking of me
speaking of me I want to give an
announcement for this weekend I know you
have one too so Sunday Sunday Sunday
Sunday instead of the Sunday ramp what
we're gonna do is have a patreon party
oh we're gonna have a party over on
patreon
on Sunday I'm probably gonna be
um getting a little drunk and I'm
probably I might I might do some edibles
with you
if you want to or not um but we're
probably going to be singing karaoke I'm
going to show you some of my favorite
comedy what the [__] are you gonna show
you some of our favorite some of my
favorite Comedy clips you guys will be
will be on camera it's like a zoom
meeting as opposed to a broadcast like
this so very special
um Gabe you're welcome to uh join yeah
yeah yeah which means you're doing that
Sunday but I think tomorrow yeah I think
the plan is to do the weekend Roundup
that I have so we'll go through all the
[__] we'll catch up I'm sure there'll be
more that'll happen later today okay
Saturday but uh Tony will be there oh so
what time is it what time is it we'll
probably do I think I think tentatively
noon I normally do it New York Sunday
noon my time Pacific Time noon okay so I
think I could probably make that okay if
we need to adjust we can because I don't
normally do on Saturday do it on Sunday
at noon but we'll do it on Saturday and
we'll figure out a time and I can be
there for a little bit so go to
patreon.com the Tony Michaels and
patreon.com I am Gabe Sanchez or let's
go to what was thatshow.com and then
I'll take you directly to the patreon if
you want to see there's a new uh a new
what was that just dropped so the people
on patreon you got the exclusive access
first early release on that which is
about the uh
uh uh which was on um wow I'm blank oh
it was on the it was on the Louisville
shooting okay right so there's a whole
coverage and I'm going to be finishing
up another what was that that you'll
have Early Access to if you join the
patreon and that next one which is
episode 42 which will be on the Webster
Barnaby you know the bigot Barnaby the
guy who called trans people mutants and
imps and demons
um so that'll be coming out later
tonight so uh there's already one early
release that no one's seen yet only the
people on patreon before never before
and then there'll be another one that's
about this guy in Florida that again if
you join the patreon you'll get Early
Access you can watch it there so go to
patreon.com I am Gabe Sanchez and
patreon.com the Tony Michaels or just
search the Tony Michaels or I am Gabe
Sanchez on patreon and you'll find it if
you want to be a part of the patreon
party on Sunday where we'll be singing
some drunk karaoke possibly and tell on
some stories and then on Saturday I'll
do Gabe for his Q and A for what was
that folks it's been a great week it's
been a great Friday I've got one more
thing and apparently in the chat and I
couldn't find it there was a great
um line because I I keep saying don't
take the shovel out of their hands and
we are staying um they eat rake every
time yeah take the rake in the face
someone said in the chat let them eat
rake
there's no better description of this
show than possibly let them meet rake
yeah [__] yeah we're encouraging it a
lot of meat rake we'll show it here how
else are we going to develop content
here on the Tony Michaels podcast if
these [__] Nazi Republicans aren't
face planting or taking the rake in the
face so let them eat rake folks make
sure to subscribe right here on YouTube
and join us every single weekday noon
Eastern 11 Central 9 Pacific on YouTube
Twitter and twitch don't forget to
follow us on Twitter that's where you
vote for bonehead of the week at Tony
Michael's pot as long as Elon keeps it
open to non-blue checks I don't know if
that's that's supposed to happen
tomorrow we'll find out if it tomorrow
is the day when people will run a poll
will be like does this does this poll
work yes or [__] Elon like something oh
you know what we should do we should run
a poll that runs through we should have
let's see what happens if we run a poll
that runs through the weekend yeah oh
yeah sure you put it up on the page page
all right all right we'll figure it out
um also follow us on Facebook at the
Tony Michaels don't forget to follow the
up wires Channel over on YouTube We
broadcast there every single day too
there's a chat that goes on on the up
wire it's going to acquire.com go follow
the up wires channel so if you're over
on the up wire and you're wondering why
you're not seeing all the chat is
because you're on the up bars Channel
not the Tony Michaels podcast Channel
but you can be on either one there's
chat either place you guys can go over
there also there's a chat on Twitch and
Gabe Sanchez did you know if you have an
Amazon Prime account you can tie it to
Twitch give that one free subscription
for twitch that you get with your Amazon
Prime account every single month and we
get a little bit of Jeff bezos's money
did you know that I know you know the
audience might not know that so go ahead
go over and and link your Amazon Prime
account to the Twitch account give us
that one free subscription you get with
your Amazon Prime account and we get a
few bucks on Amazon's money have a great
weekend I can't wait to see you guys at
the patreon party go to patreon.com the
Tony Michaels I can't wait to see you at
Gabe's q a that's patreon.com
am Gabe Sanchez great weekend stay safe
don't do anything I wouldn't do or do
everything I would do either way you
know what I mean same time same place on
Monday Surfside [__]
you've been listening to the Tony
Michaels podcast in your face commentary
of current events and political news no
rules No Boundaries I think we've made
that perfectly clear we hope you enjoyed
the show and we'll be back soon in the
meantime follow toning on social media
at the Tony Michaels and until next time
raise a fist and repeat after me
[__] em
[Music]
Murphy's mealborn headass Beacon